İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 27 Ocak 2025 Pazartesi günü 58. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar bugün yeni bir konuya başlıyoruz. Artık kursun geri kalan kısmında standart kütüphaneye ilişkin önemli öğeleri göreceğiz.
Şimdi bugünkü dersimiz krono kütüphanesi. Arkadaşlar modern C++'dan önce C++11 standardından önce
tarih zaman işlemleriyle ilgili yani date ve time ve time point işlemleriyle ilgili
C++'ın ayrı bir kütüphanesi yoktu. C++'ın içindeki C'den gelen standart C kütüphanesinin
çok kısıtlı interfejse sahip time kütüphanesi kullanılıyordu.
Fakat modern C++'la birlikte önemli eklemelerden biri de arkadaşlar Howard Hinant'ın katkılarıyla
C++ camiasında daha önce de söylemiştim belki benim en çok sevdiğim insanlardan biri
Howard Hinant'ın katkılarıyla krono kütüphanesi eklendi. Bugün krono kütüphanesini belirli ayrıntı
seviyesinde inceleyeceğiz. Krono kütüphanesi hemen her projede kullanabileceğimiz ve C++'ın
standart kütüphanesinin bazı başka birleşenlerinde de karşımıza çıkacak örneğin
concurrency kütüphanesinde bizim için önemli bir modül. Arkadaşlar kütüphaneyi iyi bir şekilde
anlayabilmek için kütüphanemizin belirli öğeleri halen standart C kütüphanesinden gelen
ara yüzle bir şekilde etkileşim içinde olduğundan time kütüphanesine yönelik bazı hatırlatmalar
yapmak istiyorum. Şimdi bunları aslında bildiğinizi varsayıyorum anlatmayacağım ama özellikle
bir soru gelirse o sorulara cevap verebilirim. Şimdi minimal olarak C'nin standart time kütüphanesinde
ki C++ da inklud ederken başlık dosyasını biliyorsunuz time.h olarak değil C time olarak inklud ediyoruz.
Arkadaşlar şimdi burada neler var? Bizim bugünkü dersimizi ilgilendirecek neler var?
Öncelikle burada bazı türler var. Bu türler calendar time ki bugünkü dersimiz için
önem taşıyor. Ben Türkçe'ye takvim zamanı diye çeviriyorum ve calendar time arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar aslında time underscore t tür eş ismiyle temsil edilen tür.
Time underscore t türünden bu değer ki derleyiciden derleyiciye değişebilir.
bazı derleyicilerde bazı derleyicilerde long long türünün eş ismi tamamen implementasyona bağlı
bir type alias. Time underscore t türünden bir değer calendar time değeri ki bu şu demek aslında
C'de bir epik'ten geçen arkadaşlar bu kelimeyi de 3-4 farklı şekilde telaffuz ediyor Amerikalılar.
Epik diyen var, ipak diyen var, ipok diyen var ama en yaygın telaffuzu epik.
Aslında normal bir de dilimizde çağ vesaire anlamına da geliyor ama burada biliyorsunuz epik
epik aslında tarih zamanda bir nokta. Mesela unix sistemlerinde epik 1-1-1970-00-00.
Hatta modern C++'la yanılmıyorsam C++ 20 standardından sonra belirli işlemlerde bu epik'ın
zaten unix epika olması garantisi getirildi. İşte o epiktan geçen saniye sayısı olarak
bir time point'i ifade ettiğimizde ona, arkadaşlar onun türüne time underscore t diyoruz.
Bunun dışında başka clock underscore t diye bir tür vardı. Bu da clock type.
Tamamen işlemci, yazımsal ya da donanımsal onun bir tikini temsil ediyor arkadaşlar.
Ve clock underscore t türünden aslında süreye geçmek için, örneğin saniye değerine geçmek için
bir de time.h başlık dosyasında clocks per sec makrosu vardı.
Evet, clocks per sec.
Unix Linux kökenli sistemlerde aynı makro bir şekilde de şuna define edilmiş durumda.
CLK, TCK, clock tick.
O zaman bizim time underscore t türümüz var.
Süre ölçümlerinde kullanacağımız işlemciye bağlı clock underscore t türümüz vardı arkadaşlar.
Ve bir takım fonksiyonlarımız vardı.
O fonksiyonları da şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Abdülkadir Akar, hocam rastgele sayı üreticisinde Apple time yaygın olarak kullanılıyor mu?
Evet, zaten bu konudan sonraki konumuz random kütüphanesi.
O yüzden hem random kütüphanesinde yer yer kullanacağım krono kütüphanesini,
hem de concurrency kütüphanesinde kullanacağım.
O yüzden Abdülkadir Bey önce burayı anlatmayı seçiyorum sıralamada.
Şimdi birkaç hatırlatma daha.
Arkadaşlar şimdi time kütüphanesindeki önemli fonksiyonlar şunlar.
Bir, hemen hatırlayalım time fonksiyonu.
Time fonksiyonunun bildirimi şöyle.
Time underscore t'ye döndürüyor.
Time parametresi time underscore t yıldız.
Yani alt parametre.
Time fonksiyonu diyor ki, bana arkadaşlar time underscore t türünden bir nesnenin adresini geç.
Benim parametrem alt parametre.
Ona sistemdeki apıktan geçen saniye sayısını yazayım.
Ama bir özel koşulu var.
Bu fonksiyonu çağırana null pointer geçme hakkı da tanınıyor.
Null pointer geçerseniz tanımsız davranış değil.
Bu size sunulan bir opsiyon.
Hiçbir nesneyi set etme demiş oluyorsunuz.
Geri dönüş değerinden de zaten aynı time underscore t türünden değeri alabilirsiniz.
Dolayısıyla şu çağrılar C++'da da yapılabilecek çağrılar.
Örneğin time underscore t, timer ya da sec, time adres sec.
Ya da time underscore sec eşittir stu time null pointer.
Hatta hatta null pointer geçmek yerine, tabi bu C'nin sentaksında mümkün değil.
Ama default construct edilmiş, bir default initialize edilmiş bir time t nesnesini geçseniz,
zaten geçici nesne olduğu için bir problem olmayacak.
Yine geri dönüş değerini kullanmış olacaksınız.
Time underscore t'den arkadaşlar başka, bir de bizim burada önemli üçüncü türümüz,
İngilizce'de broken down time deniyor.
Ben Türkçe'de ayrıştırılmış zaman diyorum.
Bu da C'de struct tm yapısında temsil ediliyor.
Tabi C++'da bunu kullanırken, struct anahtar sözcüğünü kullanmamıza gerek yok.
Tm yapısı 9 tane elemana sahip.
Arkadaşlar hepsi int türden.
İsimleri hatırlıyorsunuz.
Tm underscore moon, tm underscore year, tm underscore mday.
Şöyle bir hatırlayalım mı?
Arkadaşlar bakın.
Tm, x tabi C olsaydı struct tm diyecektim.
X.
Arkadaşlar tm underscore r saat 0.23 kapalı aralığında.
Mday ayın günü.
Min dakika.
Mon ay.
Sek saniye.
Wday haftanın günü.
Year day yılın günü.
Year yıl.
Yalnız burada dikkat.
Year yılın kendisini tutmuyor.
1900'den fazlasını tutuyor.
İkinci önemli nokta.
Year day elemanı.
1 Ocak için 0 değeriyle başlıyor.
Week day elemanı.
Wday elemanı.
Bu da hatırlayın.
0 pazar 1 pazartesi gibi indekslemeye sahip.
Bunun dışında tm underscore monda da sıfır olması, ocak olması anlamına geliyor.
Buradaki problemli eleman belki intürden tm is this, is dst, is dst.
Aslında komik, biraz da tuhaf isim.
Belki arkadaşlarım hatırlayacaklar.
Nereden geliyordu bu ben Türkçe okuyorum is dst is daylight saving time. Bu bir flag ama ilginç bir flag. Negatif bir değer olması ilgili sistemde gün ışığı tasarruf zonu bilgisinin tasarruf modu bilgisinin tutulmadığı anlamına geliyor.
Eğer negatif değer değilse zero non-zero bayrak haline geliyor. Non-zero gün ışığı tasarruf modundayız. Zero güneş ışığı tasarruf modunda değiliz.
İşte burada arkadaşlar time underscore t'den C kursunda anlatmıştım. Arkadaşlar şu saatleri bir saat ileri bir saat geri alma var ya ona daylight saving time deniyor.
Yani belirli bir tarih zaman noktasında siz ya gün ışığı tasarruf modundasınız ya da gün ışığı tasarruf modunda değilsiniz.
Peki isterseniz bir hatırlatma için basit bir C kodu yazalım mı arkadaşlar? Hem de C'yi hatırlarız. Şu anda kapalı olur. Hem C'yi hatırlarız hem de bu krono kütüphanesi için bir altyapı oluştururuz.
Ben şimdilik using direktifini kullanacağım. Bakın bakın time underscore t sec stud time adres sec.
Şimdi buradaki sec long olabilir. Long long olabilir. Benim sistemdeki epoch 11 1970.00.
Dolayısıyla dolayısıyla dolayısıyla dolayısıyla dolayısını dahil edip bu tam sayıyı yazdırdığımda Cout arkadaşlar, sek eşittir, saniye eşittir, sek aslında epoch'tan geçen saniye sayısını yazdırmış oluyor.
Şu ana kadar Iostream kütüphanesi hariç her şey C'den geliyor.
İşte bu 1-1-1970-00-00'dan geçen saniye sayısı.
1 milyar 737 milyon 996 bin 149.
Şimdi iki tane dönüşüm fonksiyonumuz var.
Ben bir tanesini kullanacağım.
İsmi Local Time olan bir fonksiyon var.
Bir de ismi GM Time olan bir fonksiyon var.
Aslında her ikisi aynı işi yapıyor ama biri arkadaşlar lokal zamanı veriyor.
Yani mesela bizim şu andaki tarih zaman değerimizi alacak.
Öbürü Privilege Time'ı alıyor.
UTSM deniyordu.
O zaman bu nasıl bir fonksiyon?
Geri dönüş değeri Strap.pm pointer'ı arkadaşlar statik ömürlü bir nesne adresi döndürüyor.
İsmi Local Time parametresi const time underscore t yıldız.
Yani read parametre arkadaşlar input parametri olarak time underscore t türünden nesnenin adresini istiyor.
Buna karşılık buna mutabil bize ayrıştırılmış zaman bilgisini tutan tm nesnesinin adresini veriyordu.
O zaman şöyle çağırabilirim değil mi?
İzleyin arkadaşlar.
Strap tm tabi c++ da tm yıldız p.
Burada tabi ki auto takdid akşın da kullanabilirim.
C'de yok.
Local Time adres sek.
Şimdi bakın şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Mesela cout belirli bir formatlama kullanmayacağım.
Formatlama için aslında tabi ki format kütüphanesini de kullanabilirim.
Onu da vakit kalırsa anlatacağım.
Efendim stup da cout bakın pok tm underscore mday ayın günü.
Formatsız yazdırıyorum.
Ondan sonra bir tire karakteri koysun.
pok tm underscore mon ama artı bir.
Çünkü indeksleme sıfırdan başlıyor.
Ve pok tm underscore year.
Arkadaşlar tm underscore year ve bu da artı 1900.
Değil mi?
Saat bilgisine gelince onu da yanına yazdıralım.
Şu araya da yine bir tire karakteri koyalım.
Evet.
Saat bilgisi içinde
pok
Formatsız çirkin duracak ama yapacak bir şey yok.
Evet.
Burayı da düzeltelim.
pok
tm underscore
ağır
Şuraya iki nokta koyalım.
pok
tm underscore min
ve
pok
tm underscore
sek
İşte bakın güneşli tasarruf modu
onu da yazdıralım.
Buraya kadar bakın.
Evet.
Benim derleyicim şu macro'yu istiyor.
Onun bizim konumuzla alakası yok.
Buraya kadar yazdıralım.
Evet arkadaşlar bu
1-1-1970'den geçen saniye sayısı
27 Ocak 2025
19-46-14
Şimdi tabii haftanın gününü de yazdıralım.
Bugün pazartesi olduğu için
bir olacak.
Bunu bir yazıya dönüştürebilirim.
Ama vakit kaybetmek istemiyorum.
İlerleyen dakikalardaki örneklerde yazarız.
see out
pok
sıfır pazar
böyle gidiyor değil mi?
1 pazartesi
bugün pazartesi olduğuna göre
ve son eleman olarak
if
pok
tm
is dst
küçük sıfır
see out
Türkçe'de şöyle diyoruz.
Bir adet ben İngilizce yazalım.
Arkadaşlar
no info
on
daylight
saving
time
if
as
pok
cm
is dst
sıfır
değilse
see out
daylight
saving
time
is
active
as
is
not
active
is
not
active
terliği çalıştırıyorum.
Bir tane küme parantezi
eksikmiş
ya da fazlaymış
evet
daylight
saving
time
is
not
active
bu bir hatırlatmaydı.
Şimdi
her ihtimale karşı
bunu buraya bir
kaydedelim
ve hızlı bir şekilde
diğer fonksiyonlarımızı
hatırlayalım.
see'den gelen
local
time
gm
yani burada
time'ı
kullansaydım
diğer kodlar
tamamen aynı
olacaktı.
ne olacaktı?
Biz 3 saat
arkadaşlar
bizim
saatimizden
görüyorsunuz
16.48
biz 3 saat
ile ilerideyiz.
Peki
onun dışında
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
struct
tm'yi
time t'ye
döndüren
çok önemli bir
fonksiyon var
ama buna
zaman ayırmayacağım
ismi
make time
şöyle yazılıyor
mk time
bunun
parametresi
struct tm
yıldız
arkadaşlar
parametresi
struct tm
yıldız
geri dönüş
değeri
time
under
score t
ama
const
struct tm
yıldız
değil
çünkü
belirli değerler
sınır dışındaysa
onu
normalize ediyor
standart
c time
kötü bahanesindeki
arkadaşlar
make time
fonksiyonu
görüyorsunuz
parametresi
const tm
yıldız
ama
tm yıldız
özür dilerim
buradaki
const pointer'ın
kendisinin
constu
geri dönüş
değeri
time
under
score t
ayrıştırılmış
zaman bilgisini
yazıya
dönüştüren
iki tane
fonksiyon var
birinin
ismi
c time
bizden
time t
nesnesinin
adresini
istiyor
statik ömürlü
bir
çar dizi
adresi
döndürüyor
s c time
da
aynı işi
yapıyor
ama
statik tm
nesnesinin
adresini
istiyor
her ikisinin
döndürdüğü
adres
aynı
yani
c time
da
s c time
aynı
adresi
döndürüyor
ve
buradaki
yazı
önceden
formatı
belirlenmiş
arkadaşlar
26 karakterlik
bir yazı
yazının
sonunda
nal karakter
var
tabii ki
nal karakterden
önce
new line
da var
bu da
dersimizde
geçecek
mesela
bakınız
doğrudan
o yazıyı
yazdırıyorum
c out
c time
adres
stek
lokalden
bağımsız
belirli bir
formatta
işte görüyorsunuz
monday
january
turkçoklar
ve
yıl
çok güzel
c time'ı
bugün
kullanacağız
eğer
c time
yerine
sc time'ı
çağırsaydık
sc time
bizden
sttm
nesnesinin
adresini
izleyecekti
mesela
ototp
eşittir
local time
adres
arkadaşlar
stk
o sefer
c time'ı
çağırmak yerine
sc time'ı
tp
pointer'ını
gönderirsem
adresini
pointer'ın
kendisini
aynı
dizinin
adresini
döndürecek
yine
burada
clock
fonksiyonu
işlemcinin
fix sayısını
programın
çalışmasından
başlayarak
döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
c'de
tabi ki
belirli kısıtlar
olmak üzere
bir eventin
süresini
ölçmek için
biraz primitif de
olsa
iki kere
clock fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
eventten önce ve
sonra
clock'ların
farkını
arkadaşlar
saniyeye
dönüştürmek
için de
clock
per sec'e
bölüyorduk
bütün bunlar
aslında bizim
c kursunda
çok ayrıntılı
anlatılıyor
burada
şimdi
keselim
bir de
formatlı
bir yazı
elde etmek
için
lokale
bağlı
str
f time
fonksiyonu
var
string
format
time
str
f time
fonksiyonu
biraz daha
karmaşık
birinci
parametresi
formatlı
yazının
oluşturulacağı
dizinin
adresi
dikkat edin
const
char yıldız
değil
ikinci
parametre
bu dizinin
boyutunu
geçiyoruz
taş mı
olmasın
diye
üçüncü
parametre
formatlama
stringi
tıpkı
printf'de
olduğu gibi
buranın da
kendi
formatlama
dönüştürücüleri
var
arkadaşlar
son parametre
de
strtm
nesnesinin
adresi
bu
c++'da
da ortak
bir
arayüz
oluşturuyor
orası
biraz
karmaşık
c++'da
da böyle
bir
formatlama
var
ama
buradaki
örnek
verelim
time
underscore
t
sec
time
address
sec
bakın
şimdi
auto
p
ya da
pp
eşittir
local
time
address
sec
tar
buff
şimdi bakın
strtm
ftime
buff
birinci parametre
alt parametre
formatlama
stringi
örneğin
%
arkadaşlar
son parametre
tp
işte buradaki
formatlama
dönüştürücüleri
belirli
tarih
zaman
öğelerini
temsil ediyor
yani
bundan sonra
yazıyı
yazdırırsam
hatta şöyle
geri dönüşlerinde
bir değişkende
tutalım
siyahat
toplam
sz
karakter
yazıldı
siyahat
taburdaki
formatlama
dönüştürücülerine
ezberlemek
çok kolay
değil
kırka yakın
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
sorudan yapılan
eklemelerle
kırka yakın
formatlama
dönüştürücüsü
var
belki biraz
abartmış olabilirim
30 yıllarında
bakın
monday
january
demek ki
birinci formatlama
% a
ay
% b
arkadaşlar
ikincisi
pardon
birincisi gün
ikincisi ay
üçüncüsü de
% y
neymiş
bu
2025'in
25'i
y'yi
büyük yazsaydım
yılın
tamamını
yazdıracaktı
monday
january
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
hatta
belki
c kursuna
katılmış arkadaşlar
hatırlayacaklar
bu
lokal
dependent
bir fonksiyon
yani
lokali
değiştirdiğimizde
o lokale
göre çalışıyor
işletim sistemi
ve derleyici
destek veriyorsa
mesela
yine
lokal
başlık
dosyasını
dahil edeyim
include
c
local
c'deki ismi
nokta
ha
ve
lokali
değiştireyim
tabi
str
ftime
fonksiyonunu
çağırmadan
önce
set
local
arkadaşlar
evet biliyorsunuz
birinci parametre
kategori
şu makroları
geçiyoruz
bütün
alayı anlamında
lokalin bütün
kategorileri
lc
all
local
makrosu
ikinci parametre
de
benim derleyicim
dil isimlerini
aynı zamanda
lokal ismi olarak
kabul ediyor
aslında bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
pointer
null pointer
ise
lokal değiştirme
işlemi
yapılamadı
null pointer
değilse
lokalin
formal
ismini
içeren
bir
yazı
döndürüyor
hatta
auto
p
eşittir
if
auto
p
arkadaşlar
biraz
cvc
pas
karıştıralım
değil
p
evet
cout
lokal
değiştirilemedi
return
bir
aksi halinde
lokal
değiştirildi
ers
put
tam böyle
cc
plot
plus
çorbası
oldu
değil mi
put
p
da
studaya
kütüphanesinden
gelen
arkadaşlar
bir satır
yazdıran
fonksiyon
şimdi bakın
turkish
Türkiye
nokta
dört
müzik
lokalimizin
derleyişteki
ismi
toplam
19 karakter
yazıldı
lokal
dependentli
fonksiyon
olduğu için
bu sefer
pazartesi
ocak
2025'e
dönüştü
arkadaşlar
ben sadece
şimdi time
kütüphanesini
hatırlattım
çünkü
yer yer time
kütüphanesindeki
öğelere
ihtiyacımız
olacak
o zaman
şimdi
öğrenle
krono
kütüphanesine
başlayabiliriz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
krono
kütüphanesi
programlamayı
öğrenmek
açısından
da bence
çok önemli
C++'ı
öğrenmek
açısından
da önemli
yani ben
bu kütüphaneye
iki ayrı
gözle bakıyorum
bir
zaten
üretimde
ister istemez
kullanacaksınız
C++'ın
başka
modüllerinde
standart
kütüphanesinin
birleşenlerinde
kullanacaksınız
ama
onun dışında
burada
gerçekten
çok güzel
öğeler var
tasarım
örnekleri var
işte mesela
burada
birazdan
göreceğimiz
süre
duration
türleri
arkadaşlar
zero cost
abstraction'ın
bence
en iyi
örneği
programlamada
buradaki
duration
süre
ifade eden
türler
yine
burada
literal
operator
kullanılıyor
C++ 14
beklendi
arkadaşlar bu arada
bu kütüphane
dinamik olarak
sürekli değişti
C++ 14
standartlarında
14 ve 20
önemli eklemeler
yapıldı
ben bu derste
C++ 20
ile gelen
eklemelerden
sadece bir tanesine
değineceğim
çünkü biraz
zaman problemimiz var
her zaman olduğu gibi
şimdi
önce
kütüphaneye
bir makro
düzeyde
bakalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
son derece
önemli bir
kavram var
demin
kütüphanenin
önemini anlatıyordum
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu kütüphaneyi
öğrenmek
sadece
C++'la ilgili
bir fayda
sağlamıyor
yani
yarın öbür gün
başka bir
programlama
dilini
kullanacaksınız
o dilin
standart
kütüphanesinde
belki farklı
biçimde
farklı bir
arayüzde
ama aynı
kavramlar
söz konusu
olacak
şimdi
bakınız
burada
önemli
kavramlar
bunlar
biri
clock
yani
saat
ölçüsüde
arkadaşlar
tabi buradaki
clock
saat derken
hour
anlamında
süre anlamındaki
saat değil
saatin kendisi
yani
wall clock
gibi
ondan sonra
arkadaşlar
time point
önce bunların
ne anlama
geldiğini
bir söyleyelim
şimdi ben
C++'ın
türlerinden
bahsetmiyorum
kavramsal olarak
clock
burada ne demek
time point
ne demek
ve
duration
ne demek
arkadaşlar
time point
tarih
zamanda
bir nokta
şimdi
şurada
bir şekil
çizelim
evet
şimdi bakın
tarih
zaman
akıp
geçiyor
bizde
yaşlanıyoruz
doluyoruz
büyüyoruz
ölüyoruz
ama konu o değil
zaman sürekli
ilerliyor
bir time point
tarih zamanda
bir nokta
yani örneğin
haziran
bir time point
efendim
bu başka bir
time point
aralık
demek ki
time point
aslında tarih
zamanda
bir nokta
yalnız
bir time point'in
söz konusu
olabilmesi için
bizim kütüphanemizde
bir
clock'a
ihtiyaç var
çünkü
time point'e
orijini veren
clock
time point
kavramı
bir neyle ilgili
arkadaşlar
bir
epoch'la
ya da
epoch'la ilgili
o orijin değeri
dolayısıyla
o epoch'tan
sonrası
ya da
öncesine ilişkin
bir time point
olabilir
epoch'un
kendisi de bir
time point
ama
epoch time point'ini
bize veren kim
cevap
clock
yani
her clock
bize bir
ne veriyor
epoch veriyor
mesela
diyelim ki
benim
clock'ımın
epoch'ı
1-1
olabilir
dolayısıyla
bir time point
bundan sonraki
ya da
bundan
önceki
bir time point
olabilir
şimdi
time point'in
ne olduğunu
anlamak
çok önemli
çünkü
kütüphanedeki
karşılığını
göreceğiz
o zaman
bakın
clock'sız
bir time point
söz konusu
olabilir mi
cevap
hayır
time point'ten
bahsedebilmemiz
için
bir
clock'a
ihtiyacımız
var
arkadaşlar
time point
bir template
time point'in
template parametresi
birinci
bir
saat türü
birinci
template parametresi
hangi
saat
türü ise
o saatin
epoch'ını
ve o saatin
arkadaşlar
efendim
duration'ını
kullanıyor
şimdi
iki time point
arasındaki
fark
bir
duration
süre
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
şu time point'e
tp1
diyelim
hatta şöyle
yazalım
arkadaşlar
şu time point'e
tp1
diyelim
şu time point'e
tp2
diyelim
ikisinin
arasındaki
farkı
alırsak
bu bir
duration
arkadaşlar
burada
şuna
dikkat etmek
gerekiyor
duration
aslında
doğrudan
neden
bağımsız
yani
bir
clock
olmadan
bir time point
olmadan da
bir duration'dan
bahsedebilirim
ama
bir
time point'den
bahsedebilmem için
o time point'in
yine
bir duration'la
ilişkisi
olması
gerekiyor
yani
time point
türünün
bağlı olduğu
bir tür
duration
türü
burada
tıpkı
pointer
aritmetiğinde
olduğu gibi
buraya
dikkat
bir
time point'e
bir duration
eklersek
arkadaşlar
yine bir
time point
elde ediyoruz
mesela
12 Mayıs
time point'den
duration
çıkartarak
time point
elde ediyoruz
ama
iki time point'i
birbirinden
çıkarttığımızda
duration
elde ediyoruz
iki time point'i
toplamak
anlamlı değil
tıpkı
iki pointer'ın
toplanmasının
syntax
hatası
olduğu
gibi
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bizim
başlangıç
noktamız
az önce
söylediğim
gibi
zero
cost
abstraction
için
örnek
bir
repor olan
duration
türleri
olacak
yani
biz önce
duration
türlerinden
başlayacağız
sonra yavaş yavaş
bunun
clock'la
ilgisini
ve
daha sonra da
arkadaşlar
time point'le
ilgisini
ilişkisini
yavaş yavaş
inceleyeceğiz
ama
ondan da
önce
anlatmak
zorunda
olduğum
bir küçük
konu
başlığı
daha var
tahmin edin
standart
kütüphanemizin
yine bir
compile time
kütüphanesi
bence çok
önemli bir
kütüphane
ratio
kütüphanesi
arkadaşlar
ratio
kütüphanesinin
başlık
dosyası
ratio
yani
include
ratio
şimdi
bakınız
bu kütüphane
öncelikle şunu
iyi anlamamız
gerek yok
tamamen
compile time'e
ilişkin
yani siz
runtime'e
önerip
kullansanız da
kullanmak isterseniz
ihtiyaç yok ama
bu kütüphanenin
varlık nedeni
tamamen
compile time'da
arkadaşlar
rasyonel sayı
işlemlerini
yapmak
yani
hani
biz
rasyonel sayı
derken şunu
kastediyorum
ingilizce bir başka
terim
fraction
yani
türçe karşılığıyla
ay
bölü
payda
ingilizce
karşılığıyla
arkadaşlar
ingilizce
karşılığıyla
efendim
nominator
ben
diyorum ya
numerator
ve
denominator
arkadaşlar
basit gibi görünüyor ama
bu da
compile time
aritmetiğinin
çok iyi bir örneği
yani her şey
compile time'da oluyor
o zaman
hemen
bir kere
ratio kütüphanesini
incelemeye
başlayalım
herkes
dikkatli izliyor
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
bazı şeyleri
doğrudan hazırladım
slide'dan göstereceğim
önce
ratio'nun ne olduğunu
iyi anlamanız
gerekiyor
ratio başlık
dosyasında
aslında
şöyle bir
metafunction
olarak kullanılan
sınıf
iki tane
non-type
parametre
template parametresi
var
arkadaşlar
ikisinin
türü de
int max
underscore t
burada
int max
underscore t'nin
ne olduğunu
söylemeye
gerek yok
değil mi
sistemdeki
en büyük
işaretli
tam sayı
türü
o yüzden
derleyicilerin
hemen hepsinde
doğal olarak
int max
underscore t
long
türünün
eş ismi
arkadaşlar
birinci template
parametresi
ayı temsil ediyor
rasyonel sayının
fractionının
numerator
değerini
temsil ediyor
ikinci template
parametresi
denominator
yani
paydayı
temsil ediyor
şimdi bunu
anlamanız çok
önemli
bakınız
bu ne
demek
örneğin
ben
hep yine
using
direktifini
kullanacağım
ratio'nun
5,7
açılımı
dediğim zaman
bu
5 bölü
kesinli
temsil ediyor
ama
bakın
çok dikkatli
izleyin
eğer ben
sınıfın
const
expr
elemanı
olan
namı
kullanırsam
pay
değerini
compile time
sabiti olarak
elde etmiş
oluyorum
çünkü
static
const
expr
eleman
arkadaşlar
den
sabitini
kullandığım
zaman
o zaman da
payda
değerini
sabit
olarak
kullanıyorum
yalnız
burada
compile time
da
sadeleştirme
işlemi
yapılıyor
ingilizce
benim
sadeleştirme
dediğim terim
bilmiyorum
bazıları
arkadaşlarım
aynı
terimi
kullanıyorlar
mı
ingilizce de
simplification
anlamında
türkçe
bir sadeleştirme
diyoruz
ama
yani
ortak
greatest
common
diviser'a
bölünmüş
hali
yani
bu şu
demek
bakınız
örneğin
8 bölü
arkadaşlar
desem
ratio'nun
8 bölü
açılımının
ihtisar
etmekmiş
bunu da
öğrenmiş
olduk
teşekkürler
Rasul
ratio'nun
açılımının
numerator'ı
8 mi
hayır
değil
8 ile 12
nin ortak
bölenlerin
en büyüğü
dolayısıyla
bu
2 bölü
arkadaşlar
dolayısıyla
bu hangi
sabit
bakın
8 değil
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
2 sabiti
yine
den
hangi
sabit
arkadaşlar
sabiti
değil
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
yani
2 bölü
burayı
anlamamız
önemli
eğer
negatif
bir kesirse
siz
virgül
eksi
deseniz
de
eksi
virgül
deseniz
negatif
değer
sadece
pay'a
gelecek
bakın
namının
şunu
eksi
8 yapalım
nam'a
bakalım
eksi
2 olduğunu
görüyoruz
8 virgül
eksi
açılımı
onun
arkadaşlar
namının
yine
eksi
2 olduğunu
görüyoruz
ikinci
template
parametresi
hayır
alan
doğrudan
değer yok
ama kendiniz
elde edebilirsiniz
ikinci template
parametresi
default
argüman
alıyor
dolayısıyla
söyleyin bakalım
ratio'nun
açılımının
deni
aslında
ratio'nun
8 virgül
açılımının
denominator'ı
bu da
dolayısıyla
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
şimdi
bunun
compile time
kütüphanesi
olması
ne anlama
geliyor
arkadaşlar
bir ratio
bir template'in
template parametresi
olabilir
değil mi
mesela
duration
türlerinde
birazdan
göreceğiz
template parametresi
arkadaşlar
aslında
ikinci template
parametresi
bir
ratio
olacak
ama
compile time
aritmetiği
burada
hayatı
önem taşıyor
şimdi
izleyin bakalım
neler var
compile time
aritmetiği
giderken
bir kere
herhangi bir
rasyonel sayının
örneğin
ratio
2 bölü
baştan da
söylediğim gibi
num'ı ve
deni
kullanarak
numerator ve
denominator'ı
kullanarak
pay ve payda
değerlerini
compile time
sabiti olarak
kullanabilirsiniz
ikincisi
çok kullanılan
bazı
kesirler
var
örneğin
1 bölü
1 milyon
yani biner
biner
gibi
1 bölü
1 milyar
ya da
tam tersi
arkadaşlar
gibi
bunların
hepsinin
tür iş ismi
var
bu çok güzel
mesela bakın
ratio'nun
çok dikkatli
izleyin
1 bölü
açılımı
tahmin edin
ilkokulda
öğrendiklerimizi
hatırlayalım
hani
santimetre
desimetre
milimetre
gibi
mesela
ratio'nun
1 bölü
açılımının
küreş ismi
milli
yani
ratio'nun
1 bölü
açılımı
demek yerine
ben
doğrudan
milli
yazabilirim
yani milli
isterseniz
bakın
pipeid
milli
oilstream
pipeinfo
arkadaşlar
typeid
milli
name
siyaf
çok eğlenceli
ratio
bütüma
ben çok seviyorum
evet
birkaç tanesini
yazdırayım
sonra bir liste
vereceğim
typeid
mesela
desi
typeid
kilo
arkadaşlar
typeid
nano
micro
typeid
centi
evet
bakın
santiyi
buraya
alayım
desiyi
buraya
alayım
arkadaşlar
işte
dekal
böyle
gidiyor
hepsini
yazmayacağım
şimdi
önemli olan
bunların
türeş
isimleri
olduğunu
bilmek
çünkü
uzun uzun
yazmak
yerine
bu türeş
isimlerini
kullanıyoruz
mesela
bakınız
aslında
izleyin
desi
neymiş
ratio'nun
1,10
açılımının
türeş
ismiymiş
centi
ratio'nun
1,100
açılımı
mili
arkadaşlar
ratio'nun
1,1000
açılımı
micro
şöyle gidelim
biraz
micro
1 bölü
1 milyon
açılımı
nano
1 bölü
1 milyar
açılımı
ama
diğer taraftan
mesela
deka
10 katı
değil mi
hekto
öyle gidiyor
deka
hekto
kilo
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bakın
deka
ratio'nun
10,1
açılımı
efendim
hekto
ratio'nun
100,1
bir açılımı
kilo
arkadaşlar
1000,1
açılımı
efendim
ciga ve
ne diyelim
bir de
mega
önemli olan
burada
mantığı
anlamak
demek ki
bir kodda
bunları
gördüğünüzde
ortada
ratio ismini
görmüyorsunuz
ama zaten
bunlar
arkadaşlar
o türlerin
eş ismi
şimdi ben bunu
bir tablo halinde
göstereyim
size
izleyin
hop
geldi
tablomuz
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
küçük katlar
şöyle gidiyor
desi
senti
mili
mikro
nano
piko
fento
ato
zepto
yokto
yalnız
zepto ve yokto
tipik olarak
long long
sınırlarını
yani
64 bit
tam sayı
sınırlarını
açtığı için
bunlar
opsiyonel
yani derleyici
verip vermeme
konusunda
seçim sahibi
küçüklere gelince
büyüklere gelince
deka
hekto
kilo
mega
arkadaşlar
giga
tera
peta
eksa
zeta
yota
yine zeta ve yota
derleyiciye
bağlı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şimdi bakın
ama bu
bu kadarla bitmedi
işin
ratio ile ilgili
güzel tarafı
compile time'da
rasyonel sayıları
rasyonel sayı
aritmetiğini
compile time'da
yaptırabiliyorum
bunlar için
meta fonksiyonlar
var
diyelim ki
iki tane
rasyonel sayıyı
toplayacaksınız
bir jenerik kodda
bakın
ratio
at
şimdi çok dikkatli
izleyelim
burası biraz
başlangıçta karmaşık
gelecek
arkadaşlar
ratio at
kendisi bir
meta fonksiyon
yani kendisi
bir structure
ama bu
öyle bir structure
ki
iki tane
template parametresi
var
her iki
template parametresi
de
birer
ratio istiyor
mesela
ratio at
ratio'nun
3,5
açılımı
virgül
ratio'nun
2,7
açılımı
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
yine
bir
n
ratio
şimdi bunun
type'ını
kullanırsanız
ratio'nun
kendisini elde
ediyorsunuz
söyleyin bakalım
3,5
artı
2,7
kaç
işte
necati
31,35
mi oluyor
o zaman
bu tür
hangi tür
yanlış hesap etmiş olabilirim
diyelim ki o toplam değeri
31,35 ise
ratio'nun
31,35
açılımı
hatta bakınız
hype id
hocam neden
type name istiyor ki
template'te zaten
ratio istiyor
sorunuzu anlayamadım
nerede
type name istiyor
arkadaşlar
yanlış anlaşılmasın
bakınız
ratio at
bir
meta function
yani
template'in ismi
ratio at
ratio at'ın
bir ratio
olma imkanı yok ki
yani şöyle düşünün
bakın
belki anlamadınız
ratio at şöyle bir template
template
arkadaşlar
efendim
ratio
ne diyelim
bakın
ancak şöyle gösterebilirim
işte
int
num
den
böyle bir template olduğunu
düşünün
bunun
arkadaşlar
hype isimli bir
elemanı var
hype isimli elemanı
bu iki
template parametresi olan
iki ratio'nun
toplamının
türünü
tutuyor
jenerik programlama
tarafını biraz
unutmuş olabiliriz
burayı anladık mı
yani
ratio at
bir ratio değil
bir meta function
yani bir
template
arkadaşlar
structure
ama
bunun
hype nested
type'ı
kendisine gelen
template argümanları
olan rasyonel
sayıların
toplamından
elde edilen
rasyonel sayı
türü
yani bu tür
zaten
ratio at türü
ama bu tür
ratio türü
ve bu türün
arkadaşlar
izleyin
nam elemanı
işte
elde edilen
rasyonel sayının
bu toplamdan elde edilen
numerator'ı
den ise
elde edilen
rasyonel sayının
denominator'ı
dolayısıyla
bakınız yazdırırsam
aslında yazdırmaya
gerek yok
bak şöyle de
constexpe ya da
inleci üstüne getirirsem
gösterir
büyük ihtimalle
bakın
arkadaşlar
35'miş
nam kaçmış
numerator
bu da 31'miş
demek ki
doğru yapmışım
rasul şimdi
anladınız mı
arkadaşlar
işte bugün
bakınız
ratio at gibi
diğer aritmetik
işlemler de
metafonksiyon
mesela
ratio at yerine
bir örnek yapalım
1 bölü 2
3 bölü
arkadaşlar
bakın bakın
şimdi ratio at değil
ratio
multiply
peki söyleyin bakalım
bu type
hangi type
cevap
1 bölü 2
çarpı
3 bölü 5
3 bölü 10
dolayısıyla
burada
belirttiğim tür
bravo
alian
ratio'nun
3 bölü
10 açılımı
ama
böyle dersem
bu hangi
sabit
cevap
3 sabiti
böyle dersem
bu hangi
sabit
cevap
10 sabiti
tabi
sadeleştirme
her zaman
aktif
anlaşıldı mı
işte bakın böyle
ratio at
ratio
multiply
hepsini görün
ratio at
ratio divide
ratio
multiply
ratio divide
bunlar var
karşılaştırma işlemleri de var
karşılaştırma işlemleri de
metafonksiyon
ama karşılaştırma işlemleri
tahmin ediyorsunuz
biraz farklı
çünkü karşılaştırmanın sonucu
boolean'dır
değil mi
yani örneğin
bu bundan küçük mü
evet küçük
hayır küçük değil
dolayısıyla
buradaki metafonksiyonlar
mesela
ratio
less
arkadaşlar
ratio
less ne demek
rastol diyor ki
tamam hocam
anladım siz yazdıkça
suggestionlar çıktı
o yüzden yanlış anladım
haklısınız
bakın mesela
ratio less
ratio'nun
bakın bir örnek vereyim
hani böyle
üniversite giriş sınavlarında
falan sorarlar ya
bakın bakın
doğrudan
compile
targıdası
13.712
virgül
27.917
arkadaşlar
13.791
çok eğlenceli geliyor bana bu işler
bölü
28.003
söyleyin bakalım
birinci kesir
ikinci kesirden
küçük mü
yani bu kesir
takip edin
kesinin
Türkçe
terimi kullanıyorum
bu fraksiyon
bu fraksiyondan
küçük mü
a küçük
b değil
tahmin edin
pardon
bu kesir
bu kesirden
küçük mü
yani 13.712
bölü
27.917
olsan değil
diyor
bakalım
peki nasıl elde edeceğiz
bu değeri
compile time'da
value elemanına
erişerek
bakalım value elemanı
trueymuş
küçükmüş
arkadaşlar
eğer false
olsaydı
küçük değil
olacaktı
anladınız
değil mi
burada
yine
ratio less
yerine
ratio less'in
underscore
v'nin
açılımı
bu da
variable template
böylece
bu isimli
meta fonksiyonlarla
ratio less
ratio greater
vesaire
ratio equal
mesela ratio equal
bir true değer
yaratalım
ratio equal
ratio'nun
7 bölü
arkadaşlar
açılımıyla
ratio'nun
14.160
açılımı
arkadaşlar
ratio equal
underscore v
true olması
gerekir
değil mi
ikisini de
2 ile çarptığım için
evet
bakıyoruz
ve bu sabitin
true olduğunu
görüyoruz
arkadaşlar
ratio'yu
kendi
template'lerimizde
de
kullanabiliriz
şimdi
buraya kadar
anlaşıldığını
varsayıyorum
işte bakın
burada da
Yostis'in
kitabında
efendim
meta fonksiyonlarımız
var
ratio add
ratio subtract
ratio multiply
ratio divide
bunlar
hem
type elemanına
tür elemanı
olarak
hem de
nam ve
den
sabitlerine
sahipler
arkadaşlar
aritmetik işlemler
ama karşılaştırma
işlemleri
sadece ve
sadece
bunun
values'u var
ve bu
value
ya true
ya false
dolayısıyla
ratio equal'ın
falanca
açılımının
values'u
demekle
ratio equal
underscore v'nin
falanca
filanca
ratio
açılımları
demek
aynı şey
buraya kadar
takip edebildik
mi
evet
arkadaşlar bakın
az önce söylediğimi
Nikolay Yostis'in
SDR kitabındaki
güzel resimle de
ifade edelim
bu
epic
ya da
epoch
nasıl bir kelime
3-4 farklı
şekilde telaffuz ediyorlar
evet
arkadaşlar
epoch için
bizim neye
ihtiyacımız var
Cengiz Han Bey
bir
clock'a ihtiyacımız var
clock yoksa
epoch yok
evet
dolayısıyla
time point
işte
aslında
nasıl bir değer
arkadaşlar
tarih zamanda
bir nokta
aslında
epoch'dan
geçen
süreyle
temsil ediliyor
dolayısıyla
duration
iki time point'in
farkı
bağımsız bir değer
olarak da
kullanılabilir
time point'leri
birbirinden
çıkartarak da
elde edebiliriz
arkadaşlar
time point'e
duration
eklersem
time point
elde ediyorum
iki time point'i
birbirinden
çıkartarak
efendim
duration
elde ediyorum
time point'e
duration
toplarsam
ya da
time point'den
duration
çıkartırsam
time point elde ediyorum
işte birazdan
kütüphanedeki
bu türleri
göreceğiz
bunlar için
bize
bir
interface
verilmiş
ve
gerçekten
bazı işlemler
çok güzel
tekniklerle
tamamen
compile time'de
yapılıyor
hemen bunları
görelim
önce
duration'la
başlıyoruz
arkadaşlar
şimdi neden
önce
ratio'yu
anlattığımı
çok iyi
anlayacaksınız
önce
biraz ön bilgi
bu kütüphane
krono kütüphanesi
fakat
ayrı bir
namespace
içinde sunuluyor
bir
nested
namespace
yani
krono kütüphanesindeki
tüm öğeler
stud namespace'nin
içindeki
krono namespace'inde
mesela bir
duration
türü
eğer
herhangi bir
using
bildirimi
ya da
direktifi
yapılmadıysa
uzun uzun
şöyle yazmam
gerekir
izleyin
stud
krono
namespace'indeki
başlık dosyasına
ekleyelim
stud krono
namespace'indeki
bakın
duration
generic
sınıfı
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
iki tane
template
parametresi var
birinci
template
parametresi
birinci
template
parametresi
duration'ın
sürenin
temsil edilmesindeki
tür
şimdi burayı
ben biraz detaylı
anlatmak zorundayım
çünkü
başlangıçta çok
karmaşık geliyor
aslında arkadaşlar
bakın
duration
her zaman
bir saniye
fakat öyle bir
saniye değeri ki
duration'ın
yani duration
template'inin
şimdilik
using bildirimleri
yapayım
duration
template'inin
birinci
template
argümanı
arkadaşlar
şu kadar
tane
şu
saniye
diyeceğiz
sadece izleyin
en son aydınlanacaksınız
şu kadar
tane
taniyenin
şu kesri
bakın şimdi
mesela
ben size şöyle
bir şey desem
17 tane
saniye
bu bir süredir
değil mi
ya da size
şöyle desem
bakın
345 tane
bir bölü
bin saniye
yani milisaniye
bu da bir süredir
değil mi
ya da şuna ne dersiniz
bakınız
efendim
5.871 tane
arkadaşlar
izleyin
5.871 tane
efendim
1 çarpı
saniye
yani 60
saniyeden
arkadaşlar
5.871
tane
şimdi eğer
süreyi böyle
ele alırsanız
burada bize
iki tane
tür
gerekiyor
biri
anenin
türü
mesela 17
derken
int mi
olacak
long mu
yoksa
5.871
deki gibi
double mu
olacak
diğeri de
ratio
mesela
ratio'yu
1 alırsam
o adet
doğrudan
saniyenin
kendisi
yani örneğin
345 tane
1 saniye
ratio'yu
1 bölü
2 alırsam
345 tane
yarım saniye
efendim
ratio'yu
1 bölü
1000 alırsam
345 tane
saniyenin
binde biri
yani o da
milisaniye
demek
ratio'yu
1 bölü
1 milyon
alırsam
6.0
bu da
345 tane
saniyenin
milyonda biri
demek
bu mantığı
anlamanız
çok önemli
ben kendi
ratio türlerimi
kendim oluşturabilirim
mesela
bakınız
kendi
duration türlerimi
bakın bakın
şimdi bir duration
türü oluşturalım
using
çok ben bunu
kullanıyorum
of sec
eşittir
stud
chrononun
duration
türünün
int virgül
arkadaşlar
ratio'nun
izleyin
efendim
1 bölü
1 virgül
2 açılımı
şimdi
half sec
nasıl bir tür
abdülkadir
deniz
half sec
öyle bir duration
türü ki
kaç tane
bilgisi
intle
temsil ediliyor
ama
saniyenin
kaçta biri
ya da
saniyenin
kaç katı
bilgisi de
bir ratio ile
temsil ediliyor
mesela
benim
half sec
arkadaşlar
min değeri
57 ise
aslında bu ne demek
57 tane
1 bölü
2 saniye
burayı anladık mı
peki
şimdi bir soru
o zaman
en çok kullanılan
süre türleri
şunlar değil mi
milisaniye
saniye
mikrosaniye
nanosaniye
ya da
dakika
saat
ya da
gün
o zaman
onlar için
şöyle bir
taktif bildirimi
yapabilirim
örneğin değil mi
ama standart
kötü fane
bunu kendisi
yapıyor
şöyle
deseydim
bakın
using
miliseconds
eşittir
arkadaşlar
duration'ın
örneğin
long
virgül
ratio'nun
arkadaşlar
bir bölü
bin açılımı
şimdi ben
bu türe
bu duration
türüne
miliseconds
ismini verdiğim zaman
Deniz çok güzel
soru
hemen cevap vereceğim
o zaman
artık ben
uzun uzun
duration'ın
long long
açılımı
virgül
ratio'nun
bir virgül
bin açılımı
yazmak yerine
bu türün
eş ismi olarak
doğrudan
miliseconds'ı
kullanacağım
işte standart
kütüphane
bize
böyle hazır
küreç
isimleri
veriyor
mesela
tahmin edin
seconds
nedir
tahmin edin
hemen şunu
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
ratio'nun
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
işaretle
tam sayı türü
olarak genelde
int max t'yi
kullanıyor
ratio'nun
int max t
virgül
söyleyin
ratio'nu diyorum
arkadaşlar
duration'ın
int max t
virgül
ratio'nun
1 virgül
1 açılımı
bravo
ama bir şey söyleyeceğim
zaten
duration'ın
ikinci template
parametresi
ratio'nun
1 virgül
1 açılımı
dolayısıyla
örneğin
duration'ın
arkadaşlar
double
açılımı
desem
bu aslında
ne demenin
kısa yazımı
ikinci template
parametresi
default argüman
olarak
ratio'nun
1 virgül
1 açılımı
olduğuna göre
o zaman
duration'ın
double açılımı
nasıl bir süre
türü
saniye
ama
kaç saniye
sorusunun
cevabının
türü
double
orayı anladık mı
duration'ın
ne olduğunu
anlarsak
her şey
ondan sonra
çorap söküyor
gibi
gelecek
mesela
hadi bakalım
bir soru daha
önce denizden
sorusunu
okuyalım
60 değerindeki
havs 2
ratio
1 1
şeklinde
kest etsek
evet evet
o işlemlerin
hepsini
zaten kütüphane
bize yapma
hakkı veriyor
yapma şansı
veriyor
şimdi bir soru
mesela
saat
saat türüne
bir eşitsin
versem
bu arada
bunlara eşitsin
vermem
gerekmiyor
zaten
standart
kütüphanede
var
o zaman
saat nedir
arkadaşlar
1 saat
60 dakika
60 dakikada
1 dakikada
60 saniye
olduğuna göre
3600 saniye
değil mi
o zaman
şöyle yazabilirim
değil mi
duration'ın
örneğin
int virgül
ratio'nun
arkadaşlar
saat
evet
60 dakika
çarpı
saniye
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama Necat
sadece
ee
payda zaten
birdi ya
anladınız değil mi
ratio'nun da
zaten
ikinci template
argümanı
default birdi ya
işte
standart
kütüphanemiz
bunları bize
hazır veriyor
tabii ki
bakın
hepsinde
ben çoğunlukla
iki using
direktifini
birden
kullanacağım
ama
kod yazarken
bunları kullanmanız
gerektiği
anlamına
gelmesin
mesela
söyleyin bakalım
bakın
gerçekten
milliseconds
aslında
duration'ın
int max t virgül
ratio'nun
bir virgül
bin açılımı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
arkadaşlar
evet
işte bütün bu
süre değerleri var
örneğin
nanoseconds
bu arada
bakın bakın
millisecond
bir şey daha göstereceğim
çok dikkatli
izin
using
milliseconds
ihtiyaç yok ama
yazmak isteseydim
eşittir
duration'ın
şuna ne dersiniz
diyelim ki
int virgül
arkadaşlar
milli
açılımı
ya zaten
milli de
ratio'nun
bir virgül
bin açılımının
türeş ismi
değil miydi
dolayısıyla
duration'ın
int virgül
milli açılımı
aslında
saniyenin
binde biri
efendim
mikro açılımı
saniyenin
milyonda biri
ama
mikro demek
ratio'nun
bir virgül
efendim
bir milyon
açılım
demek
ya da
duration
int virgül
nano açılımı
işte
standart
kütüphane
bize bunları
hazır olarak
veriyor
şimdi tekrar
duration'a
gelecek olursak
duration
şöyleydi
değil mi
izleyin
duration
template'ini
kendimiz
yapsaydık
template
type name
rip
burada özellikle
rap ismini
vermemin
nedeni
buna ingilizce'de
representation
deniyor
yani
temsil türü
türeş isimlerinde
birazdan karşımıza
çıkacak
representation
arkadaşlar
saniyenin
kaçta kaçı
değeri var ya
ona da
period
deniyor
type name
period
eşittir
situation'un
bir virgül
bir açılımı
struct
söyleyeyim
duration
bakın bakın
bakın
şimdi çok dikkat
izleyin
aslında
bu tamamen
compile time
için hazırlanmış
runtime'a hizmet
veriyor ama
arkadaşlar
bir tam sayıyı
sarmalayan bir
sınıftan
başka bir şey
değil
aslında
duration'ın
örneğin
type name'i
int alırsanız
representation'ı
ya gerçekten
burada sadece
bir int tutuluyor
yani
ikinci template
parametresi
sadece
compile time'da
kullanılıyor
runtime'da
duration demek
representation
type
yani
birinci template
argümanı
int ise
int türünü
sarmalayan
basit bir sınıf
demek
zero cost
abstraction
demek
müthiş bir şey
bakın dediğimiz
ben size kanıtlayacağım
izleyin
bakınız
şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin
using
örneğin
milliseconds
seconds
eşittir
duration'ın
int virgül
arkadaşlar
rej
mili açılımı
hadi bakalım
soru
size of
milliseconds
kaç
arkadaşlar
cevap
bence
size of
int
kaçsa
bu da o
bakın bakın
size of
int
milliseconds
arkanız
arkadaşlar
gördünüz mü
peki
söyleyin
örneğin
milliseconds'da
representation
türü
double
olsaydı
takip etmeye
çalışın
bu sefer
size of
milliseconds
kaç
olacaktı
aslında
representation
türünden
bir nis
sarmalıyor
arkadaşlar
bir tam sayı
ya da gerçek sayı
sarmalıyor
neden şimdi
size of
8 oldu
çünkü
representation
double
mesela bu
float
olsaydı
bende
float
türü
arkadaşlar
4 byte
olduğu için
4 olacaktı
anlaşıldı mı
evet
yani
aslında
zero cost
abstraction
bir
int
sarmalayıcı
tam sayı
ya da
gerçek sayı
sarmalayan
ama
duration
işlemleri
için
compile time'a
yönelik
bir
interfej sunan
basit bir
sınıf
arkadaşlar
şimdi gelelim
duration'la
ilgili
yapabileceklerimize
duration
türünden
bir nesne
aslında
basit bir
structure
class
falan da
değil
bakın şöyle
plain old
data
şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
structuration
efendim
basitleştirilmiş
olarak yazıyorum
intifal
ya gerçekten de
böyle
ama bu bir
template
birinci template
parametresi
bu valin
türü
valin ismini
ben kullanıyorum
ikinci template
parametresi
compile time'da
kullanılan
o
kesir
türü
bunu neden
söylüyorum
çünkü bu
plain old
data olduğu
için
eğer
default
initialize
ederseniz
indetermined
value
olacak
işte o
sarmalanan
değeri
erişmek için
sınıfın
count
fonksiyonu
var
yani örneğin
milliseconds
ms
şimdi bu
kaç
milisaniyeyi
temsil ediyor
cevap
milisaniyeyi
temsil ediyor
peki ben
bunun
değerini
bilmesem
kullanmak
istesem
yani o
tam sayı
değerini
kullanmak
istesem
sınıfın
count
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
eğer
milliseconds'ın
representation
türü
intse
count'un geri dönüş
değeri
int
template olduğu için
representation
türü
double
ise
count'un geri dönüş
değeri
türü
double
mesela
ben
count
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerini
standart
altlıda
yazdırsam
değeri
yazılacak
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
burada
örtülü dönüşüme
izin vermemek
için
copy
initialization
yok
yani şöyle
yazamazsınız
örneğin
seconds
s
eşittir
geçerli olması
için
ya
direct
initialize
initialization
kullanacaksınız
ya
arkadaşlar
söyleyin
direct
list
initialization
kullanacaksınız
ya da
aynı türden
bir değer
vereceksiniz
işte kütüphanemizin
c++
14'te gelen
bir başka
güzelliği de
literal
operatörleri
yani
örneğin
siz
s
dediğiniz zaman
aslında
burada bir
literal
operatör
fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
tabu
const
expr
fonksiyon
ve bu
değerine
sahip
yani
countu
12 olan
bir
seconds
oluşturuyor
dolayısıyla
örtülü
dönüşümler
sentaks
hatası
ama
duration'a
duration
atarsam
o
legal
şimdi bu ifadenin
türü
int değil
bu ifadenin
türü
seconds
işte
literal
operatörleri
burada
literal
operatör
fonksiyonları
örneğin
saniye
için
s
milisaniye
için
ms
mikrosaniye
için
us
efendim
nanosaniye
için
ms
saat için
h
gibi
hepsi
ne
almış
literal
operatör
fonksiyonları
almış
burada yapılacak
tipik hata
çöp değerini
kullanma
yani
mesela şöyle
deseydim
arkadaşlar
milisekons
ms
undefined
behavior
eğer
değeri sıfır
yapmak istiyorsanız
bakın sıfır
değil
undefined
değer
değeri sıfır
yapmak istiyorsanız
ya value
initialization
kullanacaksınız
ya da
direkt
direkt list
initialization
ile sıfır
değerini
kendiniz
vereceksiniz
ya da
eşittir
sıfır
milisaniye
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
her zaman
referansımız
saniye mi
onu değiştirmeye
yönet bir ifade
yok
saniyenin
kaçta
biri olduğunu
değiştirebilirsiniz
mesela
arkadaşlar
milisaniye
aslında
saniyenin
binde biri
çünkü
ikinci template
parametresi
ratio'nun
bir virgül
bin açılımı
ama
mesela
bakın
diyelim ki
using
half
hour
eşittir
duration'ın
kendi türümü
kendimi
oluşturabilir miyim
int virgül
arkadaşlar
ratio'nun
açılımı
30 çarpı
30 dakika
çarpı
saniye
tabi
ikinci template
argümanı
mesela
half hour
diye bir değişken
tanımlasam
half
hour
x
örneğin
desem
aslında bu
134'ün
yarısı kadar
saat anlamına
gelecek
değil mi
şimdi
işin güzel tarafı
bunları
compile time'da
doğrudan
karşılaştırma
işlemlerine
aritmetik
işlemlere
sokabiliyorsunuz
sınıf bize
zero cost
abstraction olarak
bu olanağı
veriyor
mesela
bakınız
izleyin
bir basit bir örnek
yapalım
arkadaşlar
2 saat
artı
23 dakika
saniye
arkadaşlar
burada
bu bir
compile time
sabiti mi
evet
bu ifadenin
türü ne
cevap
en
fine olan
tür
burada
en
ince
tür olarak
neyi
kullandım
saniye
o zaman
bu işlemden
ne elde edeceğim
saniye
elde edeceğim
yani
buradaki
toplam
değerinin
arkadaşlar
count'unu
ekrana
yazdırsam
see out
aslında
neyi
yazdırmış
olacağım
2 saat
23 dakika
saniye
kaç
yapar
çünkü
en ince
değer
saniye
kendi türlerimi de
bunlara
karıştırabilirim
mesela
bakın
arkadaşlar
using
ben bu türü
çok kullanıyorum
dsec
eşittir
duration'ın
arkadaşlar
double açılımı
yani
duration'ın
double açılımı
demek
yine saniye
ama
representation'ı
double
dolayısıyla
gerçek sayı
değeri alıyor
mesela
bakınız
eğer
burada
bir de
neydi ismi
silinmiş
niye sildim
evet
burada bir de
dsec kullansaydım
artı
dsec
34.876
bu işlem
yine
compile time'de
ortak bir türe
bağlanacaktı
burada şimdi
pinus pipe
dsec olduğu için
aslında
ben gerçek sayı olarak
count'u elde edeceğim
neymiş
8959.88
saniye
imiş
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
bazı örnekleri
hızlı hızlı geçeceğim
yani
benim yazdığım örneklerden
önemli olan
kütüphanenin özünü
anlamanız ki
anlaşıldı
çok hızlı geçiyorum
arkadaşlar
bu neden
syntax hatası
çünkü
örtülü dönüşüm yok
yani
int türünden
duration türlerine
örtülü dönüşüm yok
dolayısıyla
az önce söylediğim gibi
bir duration
değerini
ya böyle
initialize edeceksiniz
işte
count'u
bu durumda
345 oldu
ya
direct list initialization
value initialization
şimdi
sıfır oldu
arkadaşlar
ama
default initialize
ederseniz
yanlış anlaşılmasın
default initialize
edilmesi
kendisi
bir tanımsız
davranış değil
ama onun
count'unu
kullanırsanız
arkadaşlar
o
indetermined value'da
ya da işte
burada olduğu gibi
literal
operatör
kullanacaksınız
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
çok güzel bir
kod yazacağız
beraber
duration'ın ne olduğunu
gayet iyi anlayacaksınız
ama ondan önce
bir şey göstermek istiyorum
bakın
burada
nested type'lar da
çok önemli
neden
şimdi
milliseconds
bir duration
türü değil mi
arkadaşlar
bu türün
buraya dikkat
milliseconds'ın
örneğin
rep türü
aslında
milliseconds'ın
repi
bir
nested type
hangi türe
karşılık geliyor
duration'ın
birinci
template
parametresine
yani örneğin
milliseconds'ın
repi
büyük ihtimalle
burada
long long int
bakın int max d
olduğu için
yani ben bu
türü kullandığım zaman
hangi türü
kullanmış olacağım
cevap
işte o temsil
türünü
yani uzun uzun
duration'ın
nested type'ı
demek yerine
ya da birinci
template parametresini
doğrudan
rep ismiyle
türeş
ismi olarak
kullanabiliyorsunuz
ikinci
template parametresi
period
mesela
milliseconds'ın
period'ı
hangi tür
cevap
mili türü
hatta şöyle bir şey
yazalım
bakın
same
is same
type rate başlık
dosyasını dahil edeyim
bakın bakın
güzel bir şey yapacağız
şimdi
is same
underscore v
milliseconds'ın
period türü
mili türü
benim dediğim doğruysa
bunun ne olması
lazım
true olması
çünkü
milliseconds'daki
ratio
template
argümanı
aslında
bir bölü
bin
hatta
true olması
gerekiyor
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bu
microsecond
olsaydı
bunun
period
türü de
micro
yani ratio'nun
bir bölü
bir milyon açılımı
olacaktı
orayı anladık mı
kendi türüm için de öyle
örneğin
using
absek
eşittir
duration'ın
plot virgül
ratio'nun
bir virgül
iki açılımı
deseydim
absek'in
arkadaşlar
şurada biraz
parantez eksik
absek'in
rep'i
hangi tür
plot türü
absek'in
period'ı
hangi tür
ratio'nun
bir virgül
min açılımı
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi bakın
çok güzel bir kod
yazabiliriz
gelin
bir ratio'yu
gerçekten
rasyonel sayı gibi
standart
output'a
yazdıran
bir
operator
left shift
fonksiyonu
yazalım
bakın
template
type name
r'ye
bir duration
yazdırmak
için
ama
c++20
standardı ile
bu standart
kütüphaneye
eklendi
hemen o sorunun
da cevabını
verelim
arkadaşlar
c++20'den
önce
duration'ı
bir stream'e
insert etme
standart
değildi
ancak
işte
şimdi
yazdığımız gibi
kendi fonksiyonumuzu
yazabilirdik
ama bakın
şu anda benim
derleyicim
c++20
standardını
destekliyor
izleyin
bakın
milliseconds
cout
bu kod
c++17'de
sentax hatasıydı
çünkü
inserter'lar
yoktu
c++20'de
eklendi
bakın
kendisi
ms'e
koyuyor
hatta
cout
bakın
milisaniye
artı
nanosaniye
mikrosaniye
artı
arkadaşlar
saniye
bize değeri
ne olarak
verecek
nanosaniye
olarak verecek
görünüz mü
ama c++17'ye
alsam
bu
geçerli
değil
neyse efendim
şu kodu yazalım
ara verelim
ondan sonra
template
type name
representation
virgül
type name
period
o stream
referans
operator lab
shift
şimdi gerek yok
birinci parametresi
o stream
referans
ikinci parametresi
cost
bakın
stut krono
stut krononun
arkadaşlar
duration
açılımı
ama hangi
cevap
r
virgül
e
referans
duration'ın
nesi olsun
duru
return
os
count değerini
yazdıralım
dur.count
arkadaşlar
ondan sonra
şöyle
çarpı
yazsın
sonra da
buraya dikkat
şimdi
burada period
türü p
değil mi
o zaman
p'nin
arkadaşlar
namı
zaten sınıfın
constexperial
statik
veri elemanı
değil mi
evet
o zaman
p'nin
namını
yazdırsın
sonra
bölü
karakterini
yazsın
sonra
period'ın
denominator'ını
yazdırsın
o da
den değil mi
efendim
ondan sonra da
hatta parantez
içinde yazdırsın
çarpı
şu
evet
buraya
diyelim ki
köşeli parantez
oldu sanırım
şimdi
örnek yapalım
mesela
arkadaşlar
using
of sec
eşittir
duration'ın
int virgül
ratio'nun
efendim
30 virgül
half sec
dedi
köşeli
ratio'nun
1 virgül
2 açılımı
şimdi bu
fonksiyona
örneğin
see out
half sec
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi
şöyle yapalım
c++
17'ye
almak
zorundayım
anlaşıldı
değil mi
şurayı da
düzeltelim
şu çift
tırnak
tamam
şurada
bir hata
var
onu düzelttik
bir de şimdi
kütüvanenin
kendi fonksiyonu
var ya
karışmasın diye
evet bakın
çarpı
1 bölü
bu eğer
milisaniye
olsaydı
evet bakın
çarpı
1 bölü
efendim
saniye
olsaydı
hep saniye
yanlış yazdım
yine
sek yazdım
s
gerçek sayı
olsaydı
mesela
half sek
double virgül
using
my sek
eşitliği
ratio'nun
1 virgül
onu açalım
bak
şimdi örneğin
şöyle yazsaydım
siyahat
my sek
4.56
evet
çarpı
1 bölü
olur
bir ara verelim
saat
21.05
arkadaşlar
21.04
21 bölünmesin
21.25
ile devam
edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
mesela
ekrandaki örnekte
ben
half sek
ten sek
frame
bay
isimli
türleri
oluşturdum
ten sek'i
görüyorsunuz
duration
long
virgül
beka
açılımı
zaten
duration
10.1
açılımı
frame
saniyenin
10'da
biri
arkadaşlar
şimdi bir arkadaşım
şöyle sormuş
her zaman
saniye mi
olmak zorunda
orada
yanlış anlaşılma
olsun istemiyorum
aslında
süre
saniye
değil
yani
örneğin
transek
10 saniye
minutes
dakika
ama
temsil edilirken
dakika olarak
temsil edilmiyor
şu kadar
tane
saniyenin
60 katından
gibi temsil ediliyor
ama biz ona
dakika
diyoruz
yani onun
count'unu
aldığımızda
count değeri
zaten
dakikaya
karşılık geliyor
burayı anladık
değil mi
evet bakın
şimdi
türleri
yazdırayım
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
çok önemli bir
işlem daha var
dönüşümler
burada
şöyle bir
kural var
biraz başlangıçta
anlamak zor olabilir
şimdi
İngilizce'de
kullanılan
şu niteleyicilere
bakalım
biri
coarse
kaba
anlamında
bir
yeri
fine
daha ince
anlamında
bunlar
türleri
nitelerken
şu anlamda
kullanıyor
mesela
bir
coarse
type
ya da
fine
type
eğer
daha ince
bir türden
daha kaba
bir türe
dönüşüm yaparsak
arkadaşlar
veri kaybı
olur
öyle değil mi
yani örneğin
milisaniye değerini
saate atarsanız
veri kaybı
olur
ama saati
milisaniyeye
dönüştürürseniz
biberi kaybı
olmaz
buradaki
kütüphane de
şöyle davranıyor
fine bir türden
yani finer
bir type'dan
coarser
bir type'a
örtülü
dönüşüm
yok
eğer bu
dönüşümü
yapmak
isterseniz
tür dönüştürme
operatörü
gibi görev
yapan
template
fonksiyon
şablonu
duration
cast'i
kullanıyorsunuz
ama
aksi halde
zaten
örtülü dönüşüm
var
mesela bakınız
izleyin
yüz yirmi üç
nokta kırk beş
milisaniye
ben şimdi
milisaniyeyi
saniye türünden
bir değişkene
atamaya kalksam
ya da ilk değer
olarak versem
sentaks
atası olacak
çünkü daha ince
bir türden
daha kaba
bir türe
dönüşüm
yapıyorum
ama tersi
olsaydı
mesela bu
arkadaşlar
mil
deminki örnekte
gerçek sayı
kullandım
diyelim ki
bu
milisaniye
olsaydı
saniyeye dönüşmüyor
ama tersi
olsaydı
örneğin
iki yüz otuz
dört saniye
milisekans
şimdi
sentaks
hatası yok
ama diğer
dönüşümü
bilerek
isteyerek
yapıyorsam
o zaman
duration cast'i
kullanacağım
duration cast
template
argümanı
olarak
türü
yazıyorsunuz
örneğin
seconds'ı
ve
argüman
yalnız
burada
veri kaybı
her zaman
falan kısmının
kaybedilmesi
şeklinde
oluyor
yani örneğin
buradaki
saniye
efendim
yukarıya
ya da aşağıya
tamamlanmıyor
fazla kısmı
doğrudan
atılıyor
eğer yukarıya
ya da aşağıya
tamamlanmasını
ya da
yuvarlanmasını
istiyorsanız
o zaman
flor
aşağıya
yuvarlamak
için
feeling
yukarı
tamamlamak
için
round
da
yuvarlamak
için
orayı anladık mı
ama özellikle
bakın o fazla
kısmın
kaybedilmesi
özellikle
bazı işlemlerde
bize ne yapacak
fayda sağlayacak
karşılaştırma
işlemleri
doğrudan
interfeste
var
yani
duration
değerlerini
template
argümanlarının
ne olduğundan
bağımsız
karşılaştırma
operatörlerinin
operanda yapabilirsiniz
biraz bu arada
bir önemli
nokta
şimdi şöyle
dedik ya
daha ince
bir türden
daha kaba
bir türe
örtülü dönüşüm
yok
ama daha
kaba türde
eğer
birinci template
parametresine
karşılık gelen
template argümanın
gerçek sayı
türü ise
her zaman
örtülü dönüşüm
var
yani örneğin
şöyle olsaydı
bakım ötüm
using
dsec
eşittir
duration'ın
double açılımı
şimdi şöyle
yazabilir miyim
dsec
eşittir
bu kadar
umarım taşmamıştır
long long
nano saniye
bakın
şimdi
sentax hatası
yok
seki
yazdırdığım
zaman
c++
gerçekten
hangi
değersi
onun yazıldığını
göreceksiniz
o zaman
tekrar etmek
gerekirse
kaba türden
ince türe
örtülü dönüşüm
var
ince türden
daha kaba türe
örtülü dönüşüm
yok
eğer de
illa
daha ince
bir türden
daha kaba
bir türe
dönüşüme
zorlamak
istiyorsak
duration cast
floor
ya da
seal
ceiling
ya da
round
templatelerinden
birini
kullanacağız
sınıfın
min ve
max
fonksiyonları
olabilecek
en küçük
ve en büyük
değerleri
döndürüyor
yani örneğin
seconds'ın
min fonksiyonunun
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeri
olan
saniye
değerinin
count'unu
yazdırırsam
ki
c++
20 ile
doğrudan
bunu
bu şekilde
yazdırabilelim
yoksa
c++
20 öncesinde
count değerini
yazdırmam
lazım
ya da
kendim
fonksiyon
yazmam
gerekir
max'i
evet
bakın
minimum ve
maksimum
değerler
arkadaşlar
artı artı
operatörü
eksi eksi
overload edilmiş
durumda
şu örneğe
bakın
biraz hızlı
geçeceğim artık
epey süre
harcadık
yine benim
daha önce
yazdığım
fonksiyon
duration'ı
yazdırmak için
halfsec ve
frame türünü
oluşturdum
ama burada
frame'in
representation'ı
double
ve saniyenin
bir bölü
onu
bir de
day diye
bir tür oluşturdum
arkadaşlar
bu arada
c++
17'de
day
days ismiyle
yoktu
week
weeks ismiyle
yoktu
year
years ismiyle
yoktu
bunlar c++
20 standartıyla
eklendi
yani nasıl
seconds
milliseconds
hour
gibi
duration türleri
varsa
şimdi artık
days
weeks
years
türleri de
c++
20 ile
eklendi
bakın şimdi
half sektöründen
değişken
artı artı
operatörünün
operandı
olduğunda
değeri
count değeri
1 artacak
derken
half sektörse
onun
count'u
1 artacak
mesela
bakınız
131 iken
131 çarpı
1 bölü 2
takip edebiliyor muyuz
128'miş
129 oldu
130 oldu
131 oldu
artı artı
operatörünün
operandı
yaptığım için
evet
ve dönüşümlere
bakın
şurada
arkadaşlar
mesela
duration
cast ile
x'i
d türüne
dönüştürüyorum
oysa
x'in türü
half sec
daha kaba
bir türe
dönüştürdüğüm zaman
duration
cast'i
kullanıyorum
zaten
kullanmasam
syntax
hatası
olacak
evet
arkadaşlar
bakın
bazı güzel
işlemler
neler yapabiliriz
çeşitli örnekler
vereceğim
sonra da
clock ve
time pointer'lerine
geçeceğiz
arkadaşlar burada
dikkat ederseniz
print duration
isimli bir fonksiyon
yazdım
fonksiyonun
parametresi
nanoseconds
şimdi buraya dikkat
bu da önemli bir bilgi
şimdi ben duration ile ilgili bir fonksiyon yazarken
a duration bir sınıf şablonu
fonksiyonun parametresinin bu örnekte olduğu gibi
o sınıf şablonunun bir specialization'ı yapabilirim
yani chrononun nanoseconds'ı artık bir specialization değil mi
yani duration sınıf şablonunun bir specialization'ı
dolayısıyla bu fonksiyona gelen değer nanosaniye
ama bakın şimdi day türünü oluşturdum ki c++20 ile zaten otomatik olarak geliyor
bu örnek çok öğretici
duration cast de days türüne arkadaşlar cast ediyorum
tabi c++20 olduğu için sentaks hatası vermeyecek
c++20 öncesinde kendi türümü kullanacağım
evet nanosaniyeyi güne çevirdim fazlasını attı
böylece gün değerini elde ettim
şimdi çıkartma işlemini de desteklediği için nanosaniyeden günü çıkarttım
geriye kalan yine nanosaniye
kalan değeri hours türüne cast ettim
böylece fazlalık atıldı
saat kısmını da aldım
nanosaniyeden saati çıkarttım
sonra dakika türüne cast ettim
dakikayı çıkardım
saniye türüne cast ettim
böylece bakınız arkadaşlar nanosaniyeyi gün saat dakika ve saniye olarak yazdırdım
mesela 31. satırda
print duration fonksiyonunun birinci parametresi benden o stream referans alıyordu
sea out mesnesini gönderdim
ikinci parametres neyse çok büyük bir nanosaniye diye gönderdim
ama bunun büyük bir nanosaniye olduğuna bakmayın
sonuçta nanosaniye demek saniyenin milyarda biri demek değil mi?
dolayısıyla bakalım ben de bilmiyorum neye denk gelecek
evet bakın bir gün 20 saat 57 dakika ve 3 saniyeymiş
bu nanosaniye değeri
ha burada güzel bir olanak
bir de şunu hatırlamanızı istiyorum
geçen derslerden birinde
sorularınıza cevap vereceğim
ben size literal operators konusunu anlatmıştım
ve kendi literal operatörlerimizin nasıl yazılacağını da söylemiştim
nasıl yazılabileceğini
arkadaşlar mesela
gerçekten de
ben bir gerçek sayı türü için
literal operatör
representation'ı gerçek sayı türü olan
bir literal operatör fonksiyonu yazabilirim
bakın şimdi using
diyeysek yine hep aynı tür
efendim stud
chrono'nun
duration'ın
double açılımı
tabi ikinci template parametresi
ratio'nun 1,1 açılımı
ama şimdi bakın
constexpr
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş değeri desek
yani yukarıdaki tür
literal operatör fonksiyonu tanımı
underscore olmak zorunda
user defined olanların
parametre gerçek sayı türü olacaksa
long double olmak zorunda
hatırlayın
evet
ve aslında bakın
return
besec
tabi static cast
operatörünü kullanıyorum
static cast
double
long double
parametreyi de
isim verelim
sec
evet mesela
siyahat
45.98
double
saniye
evet görüyorsunuz
45.98
s
burada
underscore
disek
aslında ne döndürdü
doğrudan
disek türünden
değer döndürdü
ama yazdırma işlemini yapan
standart tütüphanenin
fonksiyonu burada
Deniz Akkoş
dersin başında gösterdiğimiz
tme formatını
oturtabiliyor muyuz
evet
ama bakın
şimdi çok güzel bir soru
o formatla ilgili
işlemler yapmak için
duration'ı kullanamayız
duration çünkü bir süre
onun için
time point türüne
ihtiyacımız var
yani o dönüşümler
time point ile ilgili
çünkü
time underscore t
yine aslında bir
time point değeri
ama farklı şekilde
ifade edilmiş
bunlar arasındaki
dönüşümleri
yapabilmek için
bizim bir saat türüne
clock türüne
ihtiyacımız var
ona da
geleceğiz
arkadaşlar
evet
birkaç tane hızlı
örnek üstünden
geçelim
ondan sonra
evet
arkadaşlar bunlar
bu örnekler
özellikle böyle
sık üretimde
yapılma ihtimali
olan kodlar
şimdi buraya bakalım
s45 isimli
bir değişkenim var
saniye değeri
yani 45 saniye
mayday isimli
bir değişkenim var
saat türünden
yani mayday
24 saat
seconds türünden
sec underscore
45 de
45 saniye
bir de
millisecond türünden
mesek değişkenim var
onun değeri de
sıfır
şimdi bakın
milisaniye
artı eşit
ikisini
toplayabiliyorum
böylece
ikisinin
ortak
türü olan
en ince
türe
dönüşecek
ve
count değerini
aldığımda
yazdırabileceğim ki
c++20 ile
işte aşağıda
göstermişim
doğrudan da
yazdırabiliyorum
eksi eksi
operatörün
operandı
yapabiliyorum
artı eşit
çarpı eşit
gibi operatörlerin
operandı
yapabiliyorum
yani bu kodda
hiçbir
syntax hatası
yok
evet
arkadaşlar bakın
yine çok güzel
bir örnek daha
neler yapabiliriz
duration
türleriyle
şimdi bu örnek de
çok öğretici
standart
input'tan
milisaniye
türünden
bir değer
istiyorum
istediğim
bu milisaniyenin
nelere dönüştürülmesi
kaç saat
kaç dakika
kaç saniye
işte burada
mod operatörünün de
kullanılması
kullanılabilmesi
işimi çok
kolaylaştırıyor
bakın şimdi
ne yapıyorum
arkadaşlar
eğer ben bunu
saat türüne
dönüştürürsem
bunun saat
kısmını elde
ederim
değil mi
işte
bunun kaç
saat olduğu
ama fazlası
kalıyor
kaç saat
olduğunu
doğrudan
hours türünden
bir değişkene
bir değişkende
tutuyorum
duration
keste
şimdi buradan
elde ettiğim
buradaki
milisaniye
değerini
saate
bölümünden
kalan
o da bir
milisaniye
saate
bölümünden
kalanı
dakikaya
dönüştürdüğümde
dakika kısmını
elde ediyorum
arkadaşlar
burayı takip
edebildik mi
bir dakikaya
bölümünden
kalanı da
saniyeye
dönüştürüyorum
ve
artık
bir saniyeye
bölümünden
kalan da
doğrudan
benim için
milisaniye
sonra
eğer
sıfır
değilse
kaç saat
kaç dakika
kaç saniye
olduğunu
yazdırıyorum
takip edebildik mi
mesela bakın
2 milyon
345 bin
milisaniye
39 dakika
5 saniye
milisaniye
imiş
efendim
134 milyon
567 bin
37 saat
22 dakika
47 saniye
ve 333
milisaniye
imiş
az önce
söylediğim
dönüşüm
fonksiyonlarını
göstermek
için
şöyle bir
kod yazmışım
bu kod da
çok öğretici
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
microseconds
türünden
yani
mikrosaniye
türünden
bir değişkenim
var
count
değeri
7 milyon
bin
hangisi
daha ince
tür
nanosaniye
mi
mikrosaniye
tabi ki
nanosaniye
dolayısıyla
daha kapa
bir türden
daha ince
bir türe
dönüşüm
örtülü
olarak
yapılıyor
eğer ben
mikrosaniyeden
milisaniyeye
dönüşüm
yapsaydım
dönüşüme
zorlasaydım
sentaks
hatası
olacaktı
ama
bakın
mikrosaniyeyi
milisaniyeye
dönüştürmek
için duration
cast
kullandım
fakat
burada
fazlası
gitti
ama
aynı dönüşümü
ceiling
fonksiyonuyla
yapsaydım
aşağı
verecekti
değeri
bu da
aynı
değeri
olacaktı
yukarı
verecekti
floor
fonksiyonu
aşağı
tamamlayacaktı
round
fonksiyonu
da
yuvarlayacaktı
bakın
şimdi
örneğe
evet
şimdi burada
yazdırılan
değerler
aslında
bakın
654'den sonra
7 var
fazlasını
yukarı
tamamladı
arkadaşlar
yani aşağı
tamamlama
yukarı
için
ne yapıyoruz
bir de
yuvarlama
yuvarlama ne demek
0.5'den
fazlasını
yukarı
0.5'den
düşüğünü
aşağı
tamamlıyor
karşılaştırma
fonksiyonlarımız
var
hepsi
operatör
fonksiyonu
dolayısıyla
iki
duration
türü
aynı
template
parametrelerine
sahip
olmasa da
karşılaştırma
operatörleriyle
karşılaştırılabiliyor
yine
şöyle
zamanı
oynayalım
sadece
kodun üstünden
geçelim
arkadaşlar
bool
arpa
format
site
getirdim
dsek
yine
benim
double
türden
saniye
representation
double olan
saniye
türü
şimdi bakın
543 milisaniye
543 bin
mikrosaniye
demek
dolayısıyla
şu true
olmalı
ama
543 milisaniye
543 bin
bir
mikrosaniyeden
daha küçük
çünkü burada
bir fazlası var
bir saniye
0.999
saniyeden
daha büyük
ama
burada
representation
türü
tam sayı
burada
representation
türü
gerçek sayı
ya da
yarım saniye
543 milisaniyeden
daha küçük
bu yanlış olacak
bu
543 milisaniye
doğru olacak
bu doğru olacak
gerçekten de
bir
syntax hatası
oluşturmadığını
görüyorsunuz
evet
arkadaşlar bakın
burada da şunu
göstermek istiyorum
fonksiyonların
parametresi
template fonksiyonsa
doğrudan
duration
template'i
olabilir
yani
f1 fonksiyonu
herhangi bir
duration'ı
kabul eder
değil mi
duration'ın
hangi specialization
olursa olsun
çünkü bu
fonksiyon
şablonu
öyle değil mi
ama
f2 fonksiyonu
bizden
nanosaniye
bekliyor
dolayısıyla
f2 fonksiyonuna
ya nanosaniye
ya da
ondan
daha kaba
forcer
pipetan
bir değer
göndermeliyim
aksi halde
nanosaniyeye
tür dönüştürme
operatörü
duration
cast ile
dönüştürerek
göndereceğim
ama
f3 fonksiyonu
gördüğünüz gibi
duration'ın
double açılımı
türünden
dolayısıyla
gerçek sayı
türü olduğu için
representation
type
gerçek sayı
türü olduğu için
ne yapabilirim
herhangi bir
türden
değer
bu fonksiyona
örtülü
olarak gönderilebilir
yani şimdi
şöyle fonksiyon
çağrıları
yapsam
mesela f2'yi
çağırıyorum
nanosaniye
arkadaşlar
ama
örneğin
milisaniye
değerini
argüman olarak
göndersem
tabi
using
bildirimleri
yok
evet
sentax hatası
olmayacak
öyle değil mi
ama bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
örneğin
milisaniye
olsaydı
bu durumda
sentax hatası
olacaktı
arkadaşlar
yok
yine
sentax hatası
olmayacaktı
tam tersi yapalım
bu
milisaniye
olsun
bu örneğin
nanosaniye
olsun
şimdi
sentax hatası
oldu
ama
f3'e
temsil türü
gerçek sayı
türü olduğu için
herhangi bir duration
türünden
değer
gönderebilirdim
efendim şimdi
duration ile ilgili
yeterince konuştuk
operator overloadingden
faydalanıyor
literal
operatörlerden
faydalanıyor
c++
standardıyla
inserter
fonksiyonları
hazır olarak
geliyor
karşılaştırma
işlemlerini
yapabiliyorum
compile time
aritmetiğinden
faydalanıyor
eğer
toplanacak
çıkartılacak
değerler
constant expression
ise
olarak
yani
compile time
da
sonucu
compile time
sabiti olarak
alabiliyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi gelelim
saate
şimdi
bizim
bir time pointten
bahsedebilmemiz
için
bir
saate
ihtiyacımız var
arkadaşlar
saatler
bize
standart kütüphane
tarafından
3 tane
c++
20'yi
saymazsak
3 tane
kılak türü
hazır olarak
geliyor
bu kılak
türleri
şunlar
tabi hepsi
krono
namespace
içinde
dolayısıyla
using direktifleri
olmasaydı
şöyle yazacaktım
stud
krononun
a
arkadaşlar
stud krononun
system
kılak
önce bunların
neler olduğuna
bakacağız
b
stud krononun
steady kılak
krononun
külak
ve
arkadaşlar
bir de
spüphane
krononun
High Resolution Clock. Şimdi aslında Krono'nun High Resolution Clock türü en yüksek çözünürlüğe sahip yani saniye biriminin en ince olduğu süre türünün saniye biriminin en ince olduğu tür.
Bu da çok tartışmalı çok da eleştiri getirilmiş zamanında ama diyor ki standart High Resolution Clock ya System Clock'ın ya da Steady Clock'ın türeş ismi.
Yani örneğin sizin derleyicinizde siz High Resolution Clock'ı kullandığınız zaman aslında System Clock'ın eş ismini kullanıyor olabilirsiniz ya da bir başka arkadaşım kendi derleyicisinde High Resolution Clock'ı kullandığında Steady Clock'ı kullanıyor olabilir.
Yani asıl olan System Clock ya da Steady Clock. Ben kendi adıma High Resolution Clock'ı kullanmıyorum. Hangisini kullanmak istiyorsam onu açıkça belirtiyorum.
Dolayısıyla High Resolution Clock'ı devre dışı bırakırsak arkadaşlar System Clock ve Steady Clock ne demek ona bakalım.
Arkadaşlar şimdi System Clock ayarlanabilir saat. Bu şu demek. Yani örneğin siz işletim sisteminden saati ayarladığınız zaman değerler de ona göre değişecek.
Burası çok önemli. Ya da sizin yine işletim sisteminin mekanizmalarıyla efendim belki bilmem kaç milisaniyede bir bir zaman ayarı falan yapılıyorsa o yine değişiklik yansıyacak.
Ama Steady Clock tam İngilizce tabiriyle monotonik bir saat. Yani hiçbir şekilde ayarlanamıyor.
Burada bizi ilgilendiren tikler. Her tik yeni bir tik. Bir daha eski değere dönme şansı ayarlama yoluyla yol.
Bu da şu demek. Steady Clock. Şimdi demin arkadaşım sormuştu ya Time T ile vesaire ile ilişkili kullanabilir miyiz?
İşte gerçekten de insanın istediği türleri dönüştürmek vesaire gerekiyorsa kesinlikle System Clock'ı kullanacağız.
O interfeysi veriyor bize. Ama süre ölçümleri içinde Steady Clock'ı kullanacağız.
Ama şimdi Clock'ın ne olduğu konusu biraz karmaşık.
Arkadaşlar şimdi şu using direktiflerini bir yazalım.
Ve artık size anlatırken örneğin doğrudan System Clock yazabilirim.
Şimdi önce şunu anlamanız gerekiyor. Bu saat türleri template değil.
Bakın Duration türleri template.
Time Point türleri template.
Ama System Clock, Steady Clock bunlar template değil.
Ama bakın şimdi System Clock'ın Clock türlerinin nested type'ları var.
Mesela System Clock'ın Duration türü bu saate ilişkin sürenin birimi neyse, türü neyse o.
Yani her saatin o saat için kullanılan bir nesi var?
Duration türü var.
Her saatin bir Time Point türü var.
Yine saatin Duration türü olduğu için arkadaşlar System Clock'ın Rep türü, System Clock'a ilişkin Duration türünün Representation türü.
Yani şöyle yazmakla, Arkadaşlar System Clock'ın Duration türünün Rep türü yazmakla, System Clock'ın Rep türü yazmak aynı tür.
Yine aynı şekilde, Period türü, saatin süresini ifade eden türün haydası olan tür.
Yani saniyenin kaçta kaçı.
Mesela System Clock'ın ben namını ve denini yazdırırsam, benim derli içimdeki System Clock'ın süre türü arkadaşlar, saniyenin bir bölü kaçı onu görebilirim.
Mesela şöyle bir kod yazsam, cout, System Clock'ın periyodunun namı, bölü, izleyin, ama bu da steady Clock.
Tamamen derleyiciye bağlı.
Mesela bakalım, şunları da den yapalım.
Benim derleyicimde System Clock'ın kendisinin verdiği Duration türü, şöyle bir sayalım, 3, 0, 6, saniyenin 10 milyonda biri.
Deniz Bey de C-Line'daki sonuçları vermiş.
Ama bakın, steady Clock için bu değer, sizde de aynen ben sıfırları sayıyorum, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3, saniyenin 1 milyarda biri.
Biri 10 milyonda biri, diğeri saniyenin 1 milyarda biri.
Şimdi yavaş yavaş gidiyorum arkadaşlar.
Demek ki saatlerin şu türlerine dikkat.
Aynı diyor Deniz, ben de saymadım.
Şimdi ondalık nokta, binlik ayırıcı kullanmadığımız zaman okumak çok zor oluyor.
O zaman bakın, System Clock'un, burası biraz karmaşık.
Time Point türü.
İşte konuya şöyle başlamıştık ya, hatta resme geri dönelim.
Time Point, tarih zamanda bir nokta.
İşte örneğin şu bir Time Point değeri.
Arkadaşlar, Time Point'in kendisi de bir template.
Yani burada şimdi gerçekten template'lere ilişkin çok hoş bir şey var.
Bakın, System Clock'ın Time Point türü demekle,
Time Point'in, Time Point'in kendisi bir template.
Birinci template parametresi saat türü.
Örneğin, Örneğin, Time Point'in, System Clock ve Duration, Time Point'in ikinci template parametresine bakın,
System Clock'in, System Clock'ın, Duration türü demek, aynı anlamda.
Yani Time Point, öyle bir template ki,
Template'in birinci parametresi,
Ona bir Duration kazandıracak ve ona bir Epoch, Epoch kazandıracak, System Clock.
Fakat ikinci parametresi de default template argümanı alıyor.
Eğer Duration türünü kendiniz belirtmezseniz,
Saatin, Saatin, Duration türü neyse onu alıyor.
Dolayısıyla, örneğin, Time Point'in, System Clock türü deseydim,
Burada, System Clock'ı saat olarak kullanıyor olacaktım.
Efendim, Time Point'in, System Clock virgül, örneğin, Duration'ın, Efendim, Double açılımı deseydim,
Bu sefer, System Clock'ın, Duration türünü değil de,
Benim seçtiğim Duration türünü kullanıyor olacaktım.
Arkadaşlar, evet.
Dolayısıyla, Time Point türünü kullanmanın iki yolu var.
Biri, doğrudan, System Clock'ın,
Kendi Duration türünü kullanan,
Arkadaşlar, System Clock'ın,
Time Point türü.
Mesela,
Arkadaşlar,
System Clock'ın,
Yazamadık,
Evet.
Allah'ım ya,
Klavye.
Evet.
System Clock'ın,
Time Point türünü,
Bu şekilde kullanabilirim.
Arkadaşlar,
Ya da,
Az önce söylediğim gibi,
Time Point template'inin,
Bir specialization'ını kullanabilirim.
Şimdi,
Saat türleri,
Bize,
Farklı interfesler veriyor.
System Clock,
Time underscore t,
Time'la ilişkili kullanılabilecek,
Yani,
Epoch'u kullanabilecek,
Bir interfes veriyor.
Yani,
Eğer ben,
Time underscore t'ye,
Dönüştüreceksem,
Amacım,
İnsanın anladığı,
Tarih zaman bilgisi olarak,
Kullanacaksam,
Kesinlikle,
System Clock'ı,
Kullanmalıyım.
Ama,
Beni ilgilendiren,
Bu değerler değilse,
Sadece süre ölçümü ise,
O zaman,
Steady Clock'ı,
Kullanabilirim.
Arkadaşlar,
Şimdi bakın,
System Clock'ın,
Statik üye fonksiyonları var.
Burası çok çok önemli.
En önemli üye fonksiyonu,
Saat türlerinin,
Bu System Clock'ta da var.
Steady Clock'ta da var.
Bakın,
Now fonksiyonu.
Arkadaşlar,
Saatlerin Now fonksiyonu,
Geri dönüş değerine bakarsanız,
Doğrudan bize,
Bir Time Point döndürüyor.
Hangi noktada,
Zamansal noktada çağırdıysak,
O Time Point'e.
Yani örneğin,
En sık karşımıza çıkacak,
Kodlardan biri,
Doğrudan bir saat türünü alıp,
System Clock'ın,
Onun,
Now,
Statik üye fonksiyonunu çağırarak,
Şu andaki zamana ilişkin,
Bir Time Point elde etmek.
Şimdi soru,
Bakın,
Bu ifade,
Bir fonksiyon çağırısı,
Bu fonksiyonun,
Geri dönüş değeri,
Türü ne?
Cevap,
Time Point.
Yani siz,
Now fonksiyonunu çağırdığınız zaman,
Size,
Time Point veriyor.
Dolayısıyla,
Eğer ben bu fonksiyonun,
Geri dönüş değerini,
Ototype deduction'dan,
Faydalanmadan,
Fonksiyonun,
Gerçek geri dönüş değeri,
Neyse,
Onda tutsaydım,
O zaman,
Şöyle yazmalıydım,
System Clock'ın,
Arkadaşlar,
Time Point türü,
Örneğin,
Tp,
Eşittir,
System Clock'ın,
Now'ı.
Ama burada,
Tabi,
Uzun uzun böyle yazmak yerine,
Ototype deduction'dan,
Faydalanabilirsiniz.
Dolayısıyla,
Bir,
Klux sınıfının,
Ya da sınıflarının,
Bize verdiği bir interfejs var.
Bir de,
İşte,
Now fonksiyonunun,
Geri dönüş değeri olan,
Time Point türünün,
Onun da ayrı interfejsi var.
Tahmin edebildiğiniz gibi,
İki Time Point'i,
Birbiriyle toplarsam,
Sentax hatası olacak.
Ama bir Time Point ile,
Bir duration'ı toplayabilirim.
Mesela,
Bakınız,
Şöyle bir işlem yapsam,
System Clock'ın,
Now'ı,
Eksi,
234,
Arkadaşlar,
Saat.
Soru 1,
Bu ifadenin türü ne?
Cevap,
Bu ifadenin türü,
Yine Time Point.
Hangi zamana ilişkin bir Time Point?
Bu fonksiyonu çağırdığım,
Noktadan,
Arkadaşlar,
234 saat,
Öncesine ilişkin.
Şimdi neler yapabilirim?
Burası çok çok önemli,
En fazla vakti burada harcayacağız.
Arkadaşlar,
C++ 20 standartıyla,
Bakın,
Time Point değerini,
Doğrudan,
Doğrudan standart output'a insert edebilirsiniz.
Ama bu C++ 20 ile geldi.
Şimdi ekrana yazılan değere bakın,
2 mili,
Resmen ne bu?
Bakın,
Tarih zamanında bir nokta değil mi?
Yok ki,
27 Ocak 2025,
19,
03,
17,
Bu da işte saatin,
O ne denir,
Period,
Milisaniye ise,
Milisaniye,
Makrosaniye ise,
Makrosaniye saniyenin 10 milyonda biriyse,
O değer.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Ama mesela ben buna diyelim ki,
Şöyle bir şey yazsaydım,
Ne kadar kolay bakın,
C++ 20 ile,
654 bin 312 saniye sonra,
Hangi tarih olacak?
Ya da,
Örneğin,
456 milyar,
912 milyon,
871 bin,
341 milisaniye sonrası,
Ya da öncesi,
Hangi tarih olacak?
O zaman,
Tekrar edecek olursak,
Saatin,
Now fonksiyonu,
Bize bir time point veriyor,
Bu time point ile ilgili,
Neler yapabiliriz göreceğiz,
Ama,
En azından şimdi neyi gördük?
Time point'ten,
Duration çıkartarak,
Time point elde ediyorum,
O time point'ten,
O kadar saniye,
O kadar saat,
O kadar gün,
Öncesi ya da sonrası,
Ama o da bir time point,
C++ 20 standardıyla,
Time point'i,
Bir stream'e,
Yazı olarak verebiliyorum,
Takip edebiliyor muyuz,
Şimdi biz clock'a,
Geri dönelim,
Ondan sonra time point'i,
İnceleyeceğiz,
İki tane,
System clock'ın,
Dönüşüm fonksiyonu var,
Bunlar,
Gerek Now,
Bakın,
Clock,
Tamamen,
Sadece,
Statik üye fonksiyonlara,
Sahip bir tür,
Yani,
İngilizce,
Böyle türlere,
Verilen ismi,
Biliyor musunuz,
Hiçbir member,
Function'u yok,
Yani,
Sınıf nesnelerinin,
Ayrı bir state'i yok,
Bütün sınıf nesnelerinin,
State'i aynı,
Arkadaşlar,
Böyle sınıflara,
Karşılık gelen,
Bir terim var,
Biliyor musunuz,
Yani,
Nesnenin,
Farklı farklı,
Instanslar olsa bile,
Onların arasında,
Arkadaşlar,
Hiçbir state farklılığı yok,
Buna,
Mono state deniyor,
Böyle sınıflara,
Hatta bu bir,
Tasarım örüntüsü,
Mono state örüntüsü,
Arkadaşlar,
System clock'ın,
Üç tane bizi ilgilendiren,
Statik üye fonksiyonu var,
Biri now,
Time point döndürüyor,
İkincisi,
Arkadaşlar,
To time t,
Bakın,
To time t fonksiyonu,
Bizden,
Time point istiyor,
Onu,
Time t'ye dönüştürüyor,
İşte,
Dersin başında,
Bir arkadaşımın,
İsmini,
Oğuzhan olabilir,
Ya da başka bir arkadaşımız,
Deniz sormuş olabilir,
Yani,
Time point'ten,
Time t'ye,
Dönüşüm yapabilir miyim,
Evet,
Time point'ten,
Time t'ye,
Dönüşüm yapmak için,
System clock'ın,
To time t fonksiyonunu,
Kullanıyorum,
Hepsini örnek vereceğim,
Yani,
To time t fonksiyonu,
Arkadaşlar,
Bana,
Benden,
Time point istiyor,
Geri dönüş değeri olarak,
O time point'te karşılık gelen,
Time underscore t değerini veriyor,
İkinci dönüşüm fonksiyonu,
Arkadaşlar,
From time t,
Bu da tam tersi,
Bizden time t değerini alıyor,
O time t değerine karşılık gelen,
Time point'i veriyor,
Mesela bakın,
İlginç bir şey yapalım,
Biz,
Gidelim,
Standart kütüphanemizin,
Time underscore t türünden,
Time fonksiyonunun,
Geri dönüş değerini,
Bir değişken diye tutalım,
Bunu gösterebilemek için,
Now ptr,
Şimdi,
Buna,
Şu kadar saniye ekleyelim,
Arkadaşlar,
Bu bildiğim,
C'deki time underscore t türü,
O zaman bu time underscore t türünden,
Bir değer değil mi,
Şimdi mesela ben,
System clock'ın,
From time t fonksiyonuna,
Bu time t değerini,
Argüman olarak verirsem,
Geri dönüş değerim,
Bir,
Arkadaşlar,
Söyleyin,
Time point,
C++ 20 ile de,
Time point'i,
Yazdırabiliyordum,
Stream'i,
Bunun için C++ 20 gerekiyor,
Dolayısıyla 76 bin 123 saniye sonrasını,
Bu şekilde de elde edebilirim,
O zaman tekrar edelim,
System clock,
Küçük bir interfejse sahip,
Bir monostate class,
Sadece sınıfın,
Now,
To time t,
Ve from time t fonksiyonları var,
Now fonksiyonu,
Çağrıldığı noktaya ilişkin,
Time point'i veriyor,
To time t ve from time t de,
Time underscore t den,
Time point'e,
Ya da tam tersi,
Time point'ten,
Time underscore t'ye,
Arkadaşlar,
Dönüşüm,
Gerçekleştiriyor,
Evet,
Arkadaşlar,
Bakın şimdi,
Birkaç tane örnek,
Zamanımızda,
Bir hayli azaldı,
Biraz hızlanalım,
Mesela,
Ben,
Type ID operatörüne,
Operant yaptım,
System clock'ın,
Period'ı,
High resolution clock'ın,
Ve,
Steady clock'ın,
Period'ı,
Bunların,
Hangi tür olduklarını yazdırdım,
Mesela,
Benim,
System clock'ın,
Period'ı,
Demin işte,
Deniz'de göstermişti ya,
Saniyenin,
10 milyonda biri,
Diğeri,
Saniyenin,
1 milyarda biri,
High resolution clock,
Zaten bir,
Type aliyiz,
Demek ki,
Benim derleyicimde,
High resolution clock,
Aslında,
Steady clock'ın,
Tür,
Eşismi,
Arkadaşlar,
Şimdi,
Saat türleri,
Bunlarla,
Sınırlı olmak zorunda değil,
Mesela,
C++ 20 standardıyla,
3 tane daha clock eklendi,
Ama bir custom clock türü de olabilir,
O yüzden,
Özellikle,
Generic kodlarda,
İlgili clock türünün,
Monotonik olup olmadığını,
Yani,
Adjustable olup olmadığını,
Sınamak için,
Sınıfın,
Statik bir veri elemanı var,
Mesela,
Bakın,
System clock'ın,
Arkadaşlar,
Is steady elemanı,
Bu doğrudan,
Sınıfın,
Statik bir elemanı,
Bullying türden bir değer,
Eğer,
True ise,
Steady clock'tır,
Steady olması,
Monotonik olması demek,
Yani,
Ayarlanmayan saat demek,
Ama,
False ise,
Steady clock değildir,
Dolayısıyla,
Bakınız,
Bull alfa,
See out,
Bull alfa modunu aldım,
Steady mi,
Ama,
Aynı şekilde,
Steady clock'ın,
İstedi,
Veri elemanını,
Yazdırdım,
Adı üstünde,
Yukarıdaki ayarlanabilir,
Dolayısıyla,
False değer verecek,
Aşağıdaki,
True değer verecek,
Deniz Akkuş,
System clock için,
Ayarlanabilir saat,
Dememiş miydik,
Evet,
Monoton yapma yolu var mı,
Hayır,
Arkadaşlar,
Bu ayarlanamıyor,
Yani,
Bu saatin,
Kendi özelliği,
Anlaşıldı,
Değil mi,
Bu,
Set edilebilen,
Bir state durumu değil,
Yani,
Ben,
Saatim aslında,
Steady,
Ama şimdi,
Onu ayarlanabilir,
Hale getiriyorum,
Diye bir şey yok,
Steady ise,
Steady,
Anlaşıldı,
Değil mi,
Zaten,
İnterfej de ona bağlı,
Mesela,
Bakınız,
İzleyin,
System clock,
System clock'ın,
Az önce gördüğümüz,
From time t fonksiyonu,
To time t fonksiyonu,
Now fonksiyonu var,
Ama steady clock'a bakalım,
Arkadaşlar,
Steady clock'ın,
Görüyor musunuz,
Sadece now fonksiyonu var,
İsteady veri elemanı var,
Arkadaşlar,
Ama,
O dönüşüm fonksiyonları yok,
Çünkü,
Bunun amacı,
Genel olarak,
Ayarlanmamasının,
Bize faydası,
Arkadaşlar,
Süre ölçümü,
Şimdi,
Ayarlanmayla,
Süre ölçümü arasındaki,
İlişkiyi anladınız mı,
Yani,
Siz mesela,
Bir eventin süresini ölçeceksiniz,
Milisaniye olarak,
Ya,
Orada,
İşletim sistemine ilişkin,
Ya da donanımsal,
Bir mekanizmayla,
Sizin saatiniz,
Sistem saatinizde,
Bir değişiklik oluyorsa,
Gerçekten birçok sistemde,
Birini süreler sonrasında,
İşte,
Saatin milisaniye değeri,
Ya da mikrosaniye değerinden,
Eksitmeler oluyor,
Ya da,
Programı kullanan,
Saatte değişiklik yapabilir,
Dolayısıyla,
Sizin süre ölçümü,
Bundan etkilenecek,
Ama saat monotonikse,
Bundan etkilenmeyecek,
Anlaşıldı değil mi,
Evet,
Şimdi,
Çok hızlı gideceğim artık,
Kalan kısımda,
Arkadaşlar,
Bakın şimdi,
Şu iki türün,
Birbiriyle aynı tür olduğunu,
Anlamanız çok önemli,
System clock'ın,
Time point nested type'ı,
Time point'ın,
System clock,
Açılımıyla,
Aynı tür,
İşte ben de,
Bu iki türün,
Aynı tür olduğunu,
Göstermek için,
Is same template'ini,
Kullandım,
Bakın üstüne getirdiğimde,
True değer veriyor,
Evet,
Şimdi birkaç tane,
Örnek,
Bu dönüşüm işlemleriyle ilgili,
Arkadaşlar,
Dersin başında,
Standart C kütüphanesine,
Değinmemin nedenini,
Şimdi göreceksiniz,
Geçim,
Çok hızlı bir şekilde bakalım,
Using day,
Day isimli,
Bir türeş ismi oluşturdum,
Duration'ın,
Int virgül,
Ration'ın,
60 çarpı,
24 açılımı,
Yani,
60 dakika,
Çarpı,
60 saniye,
24 saat,
Ama,
Altına da özellikle şöyle,
Not düştüm,
Bunların hepsini,
GitHub reposunda da bulabilirsiniz,
Yani,
C++ 20 itibariyle,
Zaten doğrudan,
Bunun yerine,
Days,
Türünü,
Kullanabilirdim,
Şimdi,
Day türünden,
One day isimli,
Bir değişken tanımladım,
C++ 20'de,
Böyle yazabilirdim,
System clock'ın,
Now fonksiyonunu,
Çağırdım,
Arkadaşlar,
Ona,
Onun geri dönüş değeri olan,
Time point'e,
Bir gün,
Ekledim,
Hatırlayın,
Time point ile duration,
Toplanabiliyordu,
Ve bunların türlerinin aynı olması gerekmiyor,
Sonra,
System clock fonksiyonunun,
To time t,
Statik,
System clock sınıfının,
To time t,
Statik,
Üye fonksiyonuyla,
Ona,
Time point değerini,
Argüman olarak gönderip,
Ondan,
Time t değerini aldım,
Standart,
C time,
C kütüphanesinden gelen,
C time fonksiyonu,
Hatırlayın,
Time t nesnesinin adresini isteyip,
Bunu bir yazı olarak yazdırıyordu,
Ve yine aynı şekilde,
Arkadaşlar,
TP underscore tomorrow,
Tam bir gün sonrası,
Aynı şekilde bir gün sonrası,
İçinde aynı işlemi yaptım,
Böylece,
C time fonksiyonunun,
Geri verdiği,
Geri dönüşü değeri olan,
Yazının formatıyla,
Şu andaki zaman noktasını,
Ve tam bir gün sonrasını,
Yazdırmış oldum,
Evet,
Derleyip,
Çalıştırıyorum,
Evet bakın,
Bugün,
Monday,
January 27,
22.15.56,
2025,
Yarın,
Arkadaşlar,
28,
Olacakmış,
22.15.56,
2025,
Şimdi işte,
Buradaki dönüşümler,
Önemli,
Yani ben,
Gidip de,
To time t fonksiyonunu,
Kullanarak,
Time underscore t,
Türüne dönüştürüp,
Türünden değeri,
İstediğim gibi,
O C'deki fonksiyonlarla,
Yapabilirim,
Alihan Bozkır,
Hocam,
Bu warning neden oluşuyor,
Bunun konumuzu da,
Açıklayacağım tabi,
Ama C kursunda da açıklamıştım,
Hiçbir alakası yok,
Şimdi,
Affedersiniz,
Bu salak,
Visual Studio,
IDES'i,
O geçmişten gelen,
Standart C fonksiyonlarında,
Fonksiyonu çağrının,
Yanlış bir ifade kullanması durumunda,
Pointer hatası olabileceği endişesiyle,
Bize şöyle bir uyarı mesajı veriyor,
Diyor ki,
Bu fonksiyonu kullanma,
Güvenilir değil,
Onun yerine,
C++11 standartıyla,
Eskiden bunlar,
Compiler extension'dı,
C++11 diyorum,
C11 standartıyla,
Opsiyonel hale getirilen,
Bunların,
Safe version'ı,
Diyebileceğimiz,
Sonu,
Underscore,
S ile biten,
Fonksiyonları çağırmamı istiyor,
Mesela,
ScanApp yerine,
ScanApp underscore S,
Anlaşıldı değil mi,
Eğer onları çağırmazsanız,
Size bu uyarı mesajını veriyor,
Eğer diyor,
Bu uyarı mesajını istemiyorsam,
Ki ben istemiyorum,
Şu makroyu,
Tanımlamanız gerekiyor,
Bu tamamen,
Visual Studio'ya ilişkin,
Arkadaşlar,
Yani,
Sizi doğrudan,
Eğer bu ID'yi kullanmıyorsanız,
İlgilendirmiyor,
Evet,
Arkadaşlar,
Bakın,
Şu örneği,
Evet,
Şu,
Iostream,
Include edilsin,
Bakın,
Şimdi,
Buradaki,
Arkadaşlar,
Saatin,
Saat türünün,
Eş ismini,
Değiştiriyorum,
Yani,
Clock,
Steady Clock olabilir,
System Clock olabilir,
Ya da,
High Resolution Clock olabilir,
Mesela,
Şu anda,
System Clock olsun,
Nesli,
Type'ları yazdırıyorum,
Period türünü,
Duration türünü,
Representation türünü,
Ve,
Time Point türünü,
Bakın,
Bu da,
İyi bir örnek,
Bu,
Nesli,
Type'ları anlamak,
Çok önemli çünkü,
Bakın,
Period türü,
Ratio'nun,
1,10 milyon açılımı,
Duration türü,
Aslında,
Duration'ın,
Int64 dediği,
Bendeki,
Long Long,
Long Long virgül,
Arkadaşlar,
Doğal olarak,
Ratio'nun,
1,10 milyon açılımı,
Time Point türü ise,
Time Point template'inin,
System Clock virgül,
Aslında,
İkinci template parametresi,
System Clock'ın,
Duration türü,
Yani,
Bu,
Nested type'ları arasındaki,
İlişkiyi görmeniz için,
Şu koda bakalım,
Burada,
En fazla yapacağımız,
İşte,
Bu dönüşüm işlemleri,
Arkadaşlar,
Now,
Fonksiyonunun,
Geri dönüş değeri,
Time Point ya,
Burada da,
Şunu göstermek istedim,
Eğer,
Now,
Fonksiyonunun,
Geri dönüş değerini,
Bir değişken diye,
Tutacaksanız,
A,
Auto type deduction'dan,
Faydalanabilirsiniz,
Öyle değil mi,
En kolay,
Arkadaşlar,
Bu,
Takip edebiliyor muyuz,
System Clock'ın,
Now fonksiyonu,
Evet,
Ama,
Eğer,
Auto type deduction'dan,
Faydalanmayacaksam,
Now fonksiyonunun,
Geri dönüş değeri,
Time Point türü olduğuna göre,
System Clock'ın,
Time Point türü,
Böyle de yazabilirim,
Üçüncüsü de,
Bunu doğrudan,
Time Point'in,
System Clock açılımı,
Bu biçiminde de yazabilirim,
Bunların hepsi,
Aynı tür,
Evet,
Buradan elde ettiğim,
Time Point'i,
Bu time t'ye dönüştürüp,
Örneğin,
C time fonksiyonuyla,
Bir yazıya dönüştürebilirim,
Arkadaşlar,
Şimdi bakın,
Çok güzel,
Time Point türünün,
Çok önemli bir fonksiyonu daha var,
İzleyin,
Mesela,
System Clock,
Auto type'i,
Eşittir,
System Clock'ın,
Now fonksiyonu,
Buradan elde ettiğim,
Değer,
Time Point'i,
Şimdi bakın,
Tp'nin,
Time Point'in,
Time Since Epoch,
İsimli bir fonksiyonu var,
Arkadaşlar,
Dikkat ederseniz,
Bu fonksiyon,
Bu çok önemli bir fonksiyon,
Geri dönüş değeri olarak,
Duration döndürüyor,
Ama,
Bu duration,
Neyin duration'ı,
Epoch'dan geçen süre,
Yani ben,
Örneğin,
Şurada,
Doğrudan,
Şöyle de yazabilirim,
Bu fonksiyonun,
Geri dönüş değeri olan,
Time Point'in,
Time Since Epoch fonksiyonunu,
Çağırırsam,
Aslında,
Neyi elde etmiş olacağım,
Bu saatin,
İp akından,
Geçen,
Süreyi,
Ama,
Duration olarak,
Ama tabi buradaki,
Duration,
Saatin,
Nested type'ı,
Olan Duration,
Ve,
Bu,
Duration,
Tabi C++20 ile,
Doğrudan yazdırabilirim,
Ya da,
C++20 öncesinde de,
Bunun,
Madem bu duration,
Pound fonksiyonuyla,
Bu tam sayı değerini alabilirim,
Her ikisine de bakalım,
Şimdi,
Mesela,
Şu an,
Benim saatimin,
İp okundan,
Arkadaşlar,
Ne kadar geçmiş,
Bu kadar tane,
Saniyenin,
10 milyonda biri,
Ya da,
İşte,
Yuvarlanmış hali,
Bu kadar,
Doğrudan,
Arkadaşlar,
Saniyenin,
10 milyonda biri,
Takip edebiliyoruz,
Değil mi?
Arkadaşlar,
Şimdi,
Bu videonu da,
Tahmin edin,
Nerede tipik olarak,
Kullanılıyor?
Hani,
Randomized,
Videonu var ya,
Videonu,
Rastgele sayı üretimine,
İnşallah,
Bir dahaki derste geçtiğimizde,
Bunu göreceğiz,
Yani,
Rastgele sayı üreticisine,
Tohum değeri olarak,
Program her çalıştırıldığında,
Ayrı bir,
Tam sayı değeri,
Verelim diyorduk ya,
İşte,
Burada,
Bakın,
Bunu kullanacağım,
Şimdi,
İkisini beraber göstereyim,
Random,
Kütüphanesini incelerken,
Arkadaşlar,
Daha,
Ayrıntılı göreceğiz,
Bakın şimdi,
Rastgele sayı üretimine,
İletici sınıfların,
Bir tane,
Konstruktör'ı,
Benden,
Seed value istiyor,
Mesela,
MT,
19,
9,
37,
Bir,
Random number generator,
Böyle nesnelere,
Rastgele sayı üretim,
Nesnesi anlamında,
Engine de diyoruz,
Arkadaşlar,
ENG,
Bakın şimdi,
Konstruktör'lardan,
Bir tanesi,
İşte bu,
Aslında,
Parametre,
Asigned input türden,
Ama bizden istediği değer ne?
Seed value.
Dolayısıyla,
Program her çalıştırıldığında,
Farklı bir rastgele sayı zinciri,
Oluşturabilmemiz için,
Program her çalıştırıldığında,
Sınıfı türünden,
Nesnenin,
Konstruktör'ına,
Farklı bir tam sayı geçmem gerekiyor.
İşte hatırlayın,
Seed'e,
Bunu yapan,
Randomize idiomunda,
Biz ne yapıyorduk,
Arkadaşlar,
Seed value için,
Time fonksiyonunu çağırıyorduk,
Ve,
Time'dan elde ettiğimiz,
Saniye değerini veriyorduk.
Ama,
Seed o saniye değeri de bir tam sayı.
Ama şimdi bakın,
Burada daha çok şu idiom kullanılıyor.
Biraz belki yazımı uzun sürüyor ama,
Şimdi beraber yazalım.
Biraz kafa karıştıracak.
Önce ne yapıyorum?
Örneğin,
Steady clock'ın,
Arkadaşlar,
Ya da System clock'ın,
Now fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
Buradan elde ettiğim ne?
Time point.
Bu time point'in,
Time since epoch fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
Buradan elde ettiğim bir duration,
Ve onun da count fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
Ama bu tür dönüştürmede derleyici uyarı mesajı vermesin diye,
Çünkü fonksiyonun parametresi unsight int,
O zaman buradan elde ettiğim değeri,
Statik cast operatörüyle,
Unsight int türüne test ediyorum.
Evet.
Bakın,
Ben hatta espriyi okuyorum.
En uzun videomlardan biri,
One Liner olarak bu.
MT 1937,
Sınıfın ismi,
Bu sınıf nesnesinin ismi,
Bu da onun konstruktörüne gönderdiğim değer.
İsterseniz deneyelim,
Bakın,
Üstelik burada bu saniyenin 10 milyonda biri ise,
Yani zaten programı saniyenin 10 milyonda biri,
Geçmeden bir daha çalıştırmanız mümkün değil.
İsterseniz deneyelim,
Bakın,
10 kez dönen bir döngü,
Siyah alt,
Doğrudan üretilen rastgele sayıya bakın.
Tabi bu çok büyük sayılar olacak.
Bir dağılım nesnesi kullanmadığım için.
Ya da 5 tane olsun.
Eczayı çalıştırıyorum.
Arkadaşlar bakın şimdi,
Doğum değerini değiştirdiğim zaman,
Başka bir rastgele sayı zinciri gelecek.
Gördünüz değil mi?
Bambaşka.
Evet bu,
Çok sık kullandığımız bir idyon,
Rastgele sayı üreticisinin,
Doğum değerini,
Zamana bağlamak için.
Şimdi,
Steadicluck'a gelirsek,
Steadicluck'ta,
Tipik olarak,
Sürü ölçümü işlemlerinde,
Kullanılıyor.
Mesela bakın,
Çok basit bir örnek,
Bakit bir ayrı daraldığı için,
Doğrudan,
Kodu yapıştı,
İmkânlarınızda yazabiliriz ama,
Arkadaşlar bakınız,
Sürü ölçümü aslında,
Şurası.
Steadicluck'ın,
Null fonksiyonunu çağırdım.
Buradan elde ettiğim,
Time Point'i,
Time Point türünden,
Bir değişkenle,
Sakladım,
Bunun ismine,
TP Start ismini verdim.
İşte,
Şuradaki kod,
19. ve 20. satırdaki kod,
Aslında,
Bir vektörü,
Rastgele değerlerle dolduruyor,
Ve ondan sonra da,
Standart kütüphanenin,
Sort algoritmasıyla,
Sıralıyor.
Şimdi benim vektörümde,
Bir milyon tane öğe var.
Arkadaşlar,
Dikkat ederseniz,
Burada,
TP End'ten,
TP Start'ı çıkartarak,
Bir duration elde ediyorum.
Ama,
O duration,
Milisaniye değil ki,
Mesela,
Belki,
Saniyenin,
Milyarda biri.
Ama ben,
Milisaniye olarak,
Değeri yazdırmak istediğim için,
Daha önce gördüğümüz,
Duration Cast ile,
Daha ince türden,
Daha kaba türe,
Cast işlemi yaptığım için,
Duration Cast'ı kullanıyorum.
Böylece,
Aşağıda da,
Aynı şey,
Ama bu sefer de,
Gerçek sayı saniye olarak yazdırıyorum.
Bakın şimdi,
Ne kadar bilmiyorum,
Arkadaşlar,
133 milisaniye sürmüş,
Ama bakın,
Süreyi bu şekilde yazdırdığımda da,
0.133,
354 saniye.
Şimdi bir şey göstereceğim.
Eğer ben,
Milisaniyeye dönüştürmeseydim,
Doğrudan,
Count'un,
Geri dönüş değerini yazdırsaydım.
Evet,
Bu yine süre,
Ama buradaki süre,
İlgili saatin,
Nesi arkadaşlar?
Duration'ı türünden.
Yani şimdi diyeceksiniz ki,
Bu nasıl süre,
Bu kadar,
Nedir bu,
1 milyar,
Üçsüz,
Özür dilerim,
139 milyon,
264 bin 300,
Saniye değil bu.
Bu kadar tane,
Hatırlayın,
Bunun duration'ı neydi?
Saniyenin,
Yanlış hatırlamıyorsam,
1 milyarda biriydi.
Yanlış hatırlıyor olabilirim.
Ya da 1 mily,
Dolayısıyla bunu saniyeye dönüştürmek için,
1 milyara böleceğiz.
Milli saniyeye bölmek için,
1 milyona böleceğiz.
Peki,
Bugün dersimiz burada bitiyor.
Şimdi,
Bu,
Krono kütüphanesi için,
Bir maksimum yarım saate daha ihtiyacım var.
Ama ondan sonra,
Random kütüphanesini göreceğiz,
Bir dahaki çarşamba günü.
Ondan sonra da,
Artık,
En önemli konular olarak,
Bu,
Konkurrensi konuları kalıyor.
Hocam bu arada,
X value'ları geçecek miyiz?
Arkadaşlar,
X value'ları geçmekten,
Neyi kastediyorsunuz?
Eğer şunu kastediyorsanız,
Onu ben zaten,
En fazla bir 20 dakikada,
30 dakikada anlatabilirim.
Hangi ifadelerin türü,
X value?
Eğer kastettiğiniz,
X value,
Kategorisindeki ifadelerin ne olduysa,
Onu anlatmak,
Benim en fazla 10 dakikamı alır.
Ama,
Bizim öğrendiğimiz,
Araçlar söz konusu olduğunda,
O araçlar,
Birkaç istisna dışında,
İfadenin value kategorisinin,
X value olup olmamasıyla,
İlgili değil.
Daha çok neyle ilgili?
R value olup olmamasıyla ilgili.
Peki,
R value olması ne demektir,
Result?
X value,
X value ya da,
PR value.
Dolayısıyla,
Burad'a sorunabilecek soru,
Şu olabilir.
Bir ifadenin,
Value kategorisinin,
X value olması,
O ifadenin,
Combined value kategorisinin,
R value olması demek.
Yani,
R value,
Referansa,
Örneğin,
Bağlayabilirim.
Ama,
Burada belki,
En spesifik soru,
Hangi ifadeler,
X value'dur?
Onu bir özetleyebiliriz.
Bir de belki,
X value'ya,
Örtülü dönüşüm yapılan,
Bazı yerler var.
Yani,
Bir ifadenin,
Value kategorisi,
Bazı yerlerde,
X value,
Value kategorisine dönüştürülüyor.
Peki,
Bir dahaki dersi,
Onu da anlatırım,
Burası,
Merak etmeyin.
O zaman,
Çarşamba günü,
Görüşmek üzere,
Herkese,
İyi akşamlar diliyorum.
Hoşçakalın,
Değerli arkadaşlar.
Altyazı M.K.